foreign
Century it brought revolution in every
sector like business and more hello
everyone welcome to this full course
video on machine learning by simply
learn this video will help you in the
concept and give you the ample hands of
experience building machine learning
models
we have expedient instructor who will
take Goods but before we start let me
tell you guys that we regular updates on
multiplayer Technologies if you are a
tech geek in a concern for the latest
technological Trends then Cloud designs
in the baby long time in the 18th
century BC to using electronic messages
phones analyzing satellite images in the
20th century the process of weather
forecasting has evolved as a period for
climate and recreating long-term climate
patterns have been accomplished with the
assistance of machine learning models by
examining volumes of its information by
computer
so the question arises is it possible
for a machine to learn from past
efficiences just like we humans do
and the answer to this question is yes
and this became possible just because of
machine learning machine learning is a
subpart of artificial intelligence which
is broadly defined as capability of a
machine to limited area
like humans learn from them and acquire
knowledge through experience either
directly or shared by others machine
acquired knowledge through experience
shared in the form of data let's
understand with the basic idea of how
machine Learning Works
firstly you have to input the pass data
or training data into the machine
learning model after that machine
learning model learns from the data and
creates logical models
in the end when you input new data to a
machine learning model it predict output
according to the logical models
after understanding what machine
learning is equation arises why we need
machine learning
even though machine learning is
constantly developing with countless new
technologies it is still used in
different organizations machine learning
is important because it aims with a
perspective on patterns in user Behavior
operation design and support the
improvements of new products also as the
volume of data over performs people move
in the direction of compute systems that
store data and machine learning models
can predict proper solution this will
reduce human efforts time and increase
work efficiency
neck phase Uber top organization use
make machine learning as their master
store
machine learning has demonstrated
history in almost all the sector like
marketing e-commerce Banking and many
others as of now we are well aware of
how machine learning is important let's
have a walkthrough of the advantages and
disadvantages of machine learning
before diving deep into any technology
it is very important to understand its
advantage and disadvantage here are some
advantages of machine learning first one
is low error rate if coded properly
machine learning models would have a
lower rate as compared to humans machine
learning models have incredible Clarity
accuracy and speed
automation
machine learning reduces the need for
human resources at every step as it
automatically learns and predicts the
output third one is trigger all that
will reduce human effort and get quick
results talking about Healthcare machine
learning is used for screening or to
predict healthy risk in healthcare
in education machine learning is used to
give each student an individual
educational experience or in banking
enables more accurate reporting by
automating creditors for both Banks and
customers the fourth one is Trends and
patterns identification we can identify
the numerous amount of Trends and
patterns for example the stock market
uses machine learning prediction model
to predictions for companies talk and
other Financial assets
continuous symbol using machine learning
you can see continuous Improvement in
your results machine learning is capable
of learning from the information we
provide them
as every coin has two sides machine
learning has advantages as well as
disadvantage let's have a look at some
disadvantages now the first one is
costly machine learning models are
expensive and time consuming to build
rebuild and repair the robotic repair
can reduce the time and Manpower
required to fix machine learning models
but again that is too pricey
second one is limited time and quality
resources
machine learning needs a lot of data but
it also needs good quality data to
efficient the third one words are
continuous at work and are responsible
for recording the acquired information
this keeps on building up the course for
a machine to learn the potential
information is a continuous activity
thus there is a need to store the
information different storages and cloud
services are not sufficient to store
this amount of large data and the last
one is unemployment
machine replacing human jobs can lead to
several unemployment now that we have an
understanding of the advantages and
disadvantages let's move forward and
discuss different types of machine
learning
machine learning is classified into
first impulse learning unsupervised
learning third one is reinforcement
learning fourth one is semi-supervised
learning let's Understand Each one by
one in detail
in supervised learning the machine is
trained with the help of label data with
external Guidance the machine learning
model is given as small preparation data
set to work with let's understand this
by example suppose we input data as an
image having known label data of dogs in
this way machine will learn and create
some logical models
when we import a known data the Machine
model will categorize them as per their
similarities and patterns
that is we can easily sort the unknown
input as a dog
supervised machine learning can be found
second is regression and the next one is
unsupervised learning
in unsupervised learning machine Act
without any guidance in this technique
machine act upon the data that is
neither classified nor labeled without
any external guidance for example
suppose we input data as an image having
both mango and banana which the machine
has never seen in this way the machine
has no clue about the characteristic of
mango and banana so we can't categorize
them as mangoes
yeah but it can categorize them as their
similarities pattern and contrast that
is you can easily sort the above picture
into two parts
now let's have a look at reinforcement
learning reinforcement learning is hit
and trial method in the absence of any
data the machine is bound to learn from
its experience only
let's understand with an example suppose
we input the image of a square machine
learning model will respond using the
past experience suppose it gives output
as a circle
then feedback is provided as wrong it's
an image of a square now the machine
learning model will learn from this
feedback and it will predict the cut
outboard when we input the same image
next time
rainfall and learning can be for the
classified when learning enforcement
learning
and the last one is semi-supervised
learning semi-supervised learning is a
sort of machine learning algorithm that
lies between supervised and unsupervised
machine learning or it takes label and
unlabeled data to predict the outcomes
to beat the disadvantage of supervised
learning and unsupervised learning
algorithm the idea of semi-supervised
learning was presented
the principal point of semi-supervised
learning is to utilize the accessible
information successfully
in computer programming terms and the
algorithm is a set of well-defined
instruction to solve a particular
problem
it takes a bunch of information sources
and delivers the ideal result in this
modern time there are lots of machine
learning algorithm used today in this
video we will put highlight the most
widely used machine learning algorithm
the first one is support Vector machine
algorithm also known as svm sum
algorithm falls under the supervised
learning technique
the last one is decision tree algorithm
which is most widely used algorithm in
the machine learning area the decision
tree algorithm falls under the
supervised machine learning technique
after this let's move forward to see
some tools used to train the models in
machine learning the current market is
flooded with an area of machine learning
tools like tensorflow purchasing a spark
Amazon machine learning Python and many
more which help in training the models
and the system
let's have a look at each of them first
we will start with
tensorflow is a free and open source
programming library for machine learning
key features
tensorflow to power machine learning
implementation in products like search
Gmail and Translate
and the next we have Apache singer
Apache singer is an Apache top level
project it is used for developing an
open source machine learning library key
features of Apache singer are
distributive learning memory
optimization time profiling and many
more
Apache singer is currently in use at
Kanye's Technologies City group and many
others
and the next one we have a purchase
Apache spark is formed together analytic
engine Sparks come with the features
like frequency data phone and many
machine learning tools power the Toyota
customer 360 inside platform and social
media Intelligence Center
in the next we have Amazon machine
learning tool
the most promising strength of AWS
machine learning tool is that they are
based on a highly comprehensive Cloud
platform
Amazon machine learning comes with the
features like accurate prediction
reducing operation overhead improving
customer experience and many other
magnificents like Netflix and Facebook
use AWS as their machine learning
service then we have python which is an
open source machine learning framework
in view of torch Library
features like distributive training a
robust ecosystem Cloud support and many
more
companies commonly using pythons are IBM
Qualcomm Walmart and many more
let's move forward and cover
applications of machine learning
knowingly or unknowingly machine
learning is playing a major role in our
day-to-day life here I have some
application of machine learning which
will improve how machine learning is
helping everyone all over the globe
we all use Network day to day life the
machine learning algorithm figures out
the patterns of what type of video movie
we watch and thus provide a solution
accordingly Tesla is the one of the best
companies which manufacture self-driving
cars using Electric solar and integrated
Renewable Energy Solutions caused by
Tesla are already making their way to
the market and ready to show the world
of the power
another application of machine learning
is organization
we all aware of voice assistance like CD
by Apple
Cortana by Microsoft and Alex these as
it is speech to text and use machine
learning to provide result machine
learning is also used in medical sector
to determine various diseases with the
help of machine learning the pattern and
the symptoms of disease can easily be
diagnosed
and the last one is forecasting weather
forecasting and financial forecasting
are application of machine learning in
which future outcomes are using
historical data it involves the use of
statical modeling data mining technique
and machine learning for prediction so
as we have seen all these aspects
commercially have a look at the future
of machine learning the commercial
impacts of machine learning can really
hold a huge potential to generate
significantly High productivity growth
machine learning is one of the quickest
developing field on this planet at the
present time machine learning Engineers
are in high demand the average salary of
machine learning engineers in India is 9
lakh per annum and the annual base pay
for U.S machine learning Engineers is
one lakh thirty thousand dollars
all the ventures as of now have
countless usage in machine learning
which is the fundamental inspiration
video why they are in construction in
that field technology has that in
increasing demand for professionals who
can understand and make use of the vast
amount of data present companies like
Facebook Google Tesla and many more are
constantly hiring machine learning
engineers
the future of machine learning looks
bright and will pave the path to many
more in manager
now let's look into the types of machine
learning
machine learning is primarily of three
types first one is supervised machine
learning as the name suggests you have
to supervise on machine learning while
you train it to work on its own
it requires Labor Training unsupervised
learning wherein there will be training
data but it won't be labeled
finally there's reinforcement learning
wherein the system learns on its own
let's talk about all these types in
detail let's try to understand how
supervised Learning Works look at the
pictures very very carefully the monitor
depicts the model or the system that we
are going to train
this is how the training is done we
provide a data set that contains
pictures of a kind of an apple
then we provide another data set which
lets the model know these pictures were
that of a truth called Apple
this ends the train list now as we
provide a new set of data which only
contains pictures of Apple
now here comes the fun part the system
can actually tell you what fruit it is
and it will remember this and apply this
knowledge in future as well
that's how supervised Learning Works you
are training the model to do a certain
kind of an operation on its own
this kind of a model is generally used
into filtering spam maze from your email
accounts as well
yes surprise aren't you
so let's move on to one supervised
learning now let's say we have a data
set which is cluttered in the case we
have a collection of different routes we
feed this data to the model and the
model analyzes the data to figure out
patterns in it in the end it categorizes
the photos into three types as you can
see in the image based on their
similarities
so you provide the data to the system
and let the system do the rest of the
work simple isn't it this kind of a
model is used by Flipkart to figure out
the products that are well suited for
you honestly speaking this is my
favorite type of machine learning out of
all the three and this type has been
widely shown in most of the Sci-Fi
movies lately let's find out how it
works imagine a newborn baby
you put a burning candle in front of the
baby the baby does not know that if it
touches the flame its fingers might get
burnt
so it does that way and not the next
time you put that candle in front of the
baby it will remember what happened the
last time and would not repeat what it
did that's exactly how reinforcement
learning works
we provide the machine with a data set
wherein we ask it to identify a
particular kind of a fruit in this case
an apple
so what it does as a response it tells
us that it's a mango but as we all know
it's a completely wrong answer so as a
feedback we tell the system that it's
wrong it's not a mango it's an apple
what it does it learns from the feedback
and keeps that when the next time when
we ask a same question it gives us the
right answer it is able to tell us that
it's actually an apple that is a
reinforced response so that's how
reinforcement learning works it learns
its mistakes this model is used in games
like Prince of Persia or Assassin's
Creed or FIFA wherein the level of
difficulty increases as you get better
with the games
just to make it more clear for you let's
look at a comparison between supervised
and unsupervised learning firstly the
data involved in case of supervised
learning is labeled as we mentioned in
the examples previously
we provide the system with a photo of an
apple and let the system know that this
is actually an apple
that is called label data so the system
learns from the label data and makes
future predictions
now unsupervised learning does not
require any kind of label data because
its work is to look for patterns in the
input data and organize it
next point is that feedback so guys that
is once you get the output the system
tends to remember that and uses it for
the next operation
that does not happen for unsupervised
learning and the last point is that
supervised learning is mostly used to
predict data whereas unsupervised
learning is used to find out hidden
patterns or structures in data
I think this would have made a lot of
things clear for you regarding
supervised and unsupervised learning
and act like humans by fitting data and
which focuses on utilization of
information and imitating the way that
people learn step as a volcanic series
machine learning is playing a major role
in our day-to-day life machine learning
is used in Trends and pattern
identification automation weather
forecasting and many more
machine learning is classified into
supervised machine learning unsupervised
machine learning reinforcement learning
semi-supervised learning
let's understand supervised machine
learning in detail
provides machine learning machines are
trained using label data also known as
training data to predict the results
here labeled data refers to a group of
data that have been tagged with one or
more names and data is already known to
the machine a driver-wise machine
learner image and object recognition
Predictive Analytics customer sentiment
analysis span detection and many more
after understanding what supervised
machine learning is let's move forward
and see how supervised machine Learning
Works
suppose we have a data set that includes
dogs and cats now the first step is that
we need to train the model for each dogs
and cats as per the factors like
similarity pattern shapes and contrast
now after training we test our model
using the new data set which is known to
the model and the task of the model is
to identify the new input data Machinery
Trend similarity patterns shapes and
contrast
when it finds new data it classifies it
on the basis of simulatory patterns
shapes and contracts and predict the
output
as of now we are well aware of how
supervised machine Learning Works let's
have a walk through of the advantages
and disadvantages of supervised machine
learning
before diving deep into any technology
it is very important to understand its
advantages and disadvantages here are
some advantages or supervised machine
learning
World completion problems like spam
detection image and objects recognition
and many more the second one is
optimization using past experience
supervised machine learning can optimize
performance criteria the third one is
prediction
in supervised machine learning models
can predict the output based on the past
experience as well fourth one is
reusable data we can reuse the training
data unless there is any future change
supervised machine learning has
advantages as well as disadvantages
let's have a look at some disadvantages
now
dates
reprocessing of data a big challenge for
predicting the output anyone can overlap
supervised machine learning easily it
occurs when a statical model is exactly
against straining data now that we have
an understanding of advantage and
disadvantages let's move forward and
discuss different types of supervised
machine learning
supervised machine learning can be
further classified into two problems
which are classification regression
let's see them one by one in detail
classification is a process of in which
new observations are recognized in such
a way that they can be categorized
assuming you have a group of things for
example vegetables you can categorize
them based on their property that they
have like you can arrange the potatoes
in class A tomatoes in class B capsicum
in class C
these are some popular classification
algorithms that come under supervised
machine learning first one is random
Forest second decision trees third one
is logic fourth one is support Vector
machine
moving forward let's have a look on
regression
a relationship
is used to figure out the connection
between dependent and dependent but the
variables which we are trying to predict
or forecast and independent variables
means that factors that influence the
analysis it is usually used to make
projection for example we have variable
one as humidity and variable towards
temperature where humidity will play the
role of dependent variable and in
temperature will be the independent
variable humidity and temperatures are
correlated in such a way that as
temperature increases humidity will
decrease and vice versa many
organization utilizes regression models
to predict how stocks will act from here
on this is done by breaking down the
past information honest
decision algorithms that comes under
supervised machine learning first one is
linear regression second one is
digression trees third one is non-linear
regression fourth one is Bayesian linear
regression after discussing the
advantages and disadvantages of
supervised machine learning and its
types let's move forward to see
algorithms in supervised machine
learning
in computer programming terms an
algorithm is a set of well-defined
instruction to solve a particular
problem it takes a bunch of information
sources and delivers the ideal result
the first provides machine learning
algorithm is linear regression
linear regression is equalized to
recognize the connection between
dependent variable and at least
dependent variable and is commonly
utilized to make forecasts about future
results company frequently use linear
regression models to predict future
sales this can be useful for things like
planning and arranging algorithms like
Amazon product to product collaborative
filtering are utilized to predict what
clients will purchase later on given
their past purchase history
a regression tree is worked through a
cycle known as binary recursive
partitioning which is an alternative
interaction that divides the information
into segments of branches and afterwards
keep splitting each data into smaller
groups as the technique clients is
these cities are used for dependent
variables business value for example
food which divides into segments wedge
and non-wealth further it keeps
splitting into smaller groups
non-linear regression is a type of
regression examination wherein
information is fit to model and
afterward communicated as a numerical
function simple linear regression
relates to factors with a straight line
while non-linear regression relates to
two factors in a non-linear relationship
non-linear regression can be used to
predict population growth over time
or the relationship between GDP and the
time of a country
this algorithm is a way to deal with
linear registration in this statistical
examination
inference linear equation and patient
regression can generate the same
prediction and with the help of patient
processing we can retrieve the complete
variety of inferential solution instead
of Quant estimate
random Forest is one of the most
adaptable supervised machine learning
algorithm utilized for both
classification and regression purposes
random Forest is involved at work by
researchers in numerous Ventures
including banking stocking medication
it is utilized to predict the things
which assist these businesses with
running productively like client
activity patient registry and safety a
dissident sort of tree that departs you
to conclude some kind of process used
for dependent variables predificate
values for example we want to pick
between manufacturing product a or
product b or putting resources into
Decision One decision two or decision
three decision trees are an outstanding
method for managing these kinds of
complex choices
Logistics regression is calculated
logically and chosen when the dependent
variable is category they have double
results for example
logistic reaction can be used to predict
whether a political normally will win or
lose a political race or a secretary
admitted up to a specific School
a support Vector machine is a well-known
supervised machine learning model it is
utilized for the two information
classification and regression all things
considered it is regularly utilized for
grouping issues like weekend involvement
different Life Care Systems we can
involve in typically happy and sad look
arrangement you can involve in filters
if you make specific looks it would add
the particular filter according to the
expression
the scope of articulation lies between
happy and sad
after understanding so complex machine
learning
choose from over 300 in-demand skills
and get access to 1000 plus hours of
video content for free visit skillup by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
to provide machine learning models can
be used to build and Advance several
businesses application including the
following the first one is image and
object recognition supervised machine
learning models can be utilized to find
and isolate and assault objects out of
recordings of pictures making them
valuable when applied to different
computer design strategies and image
analysis and predictive analysis a broad
use case post provides machine learning
models is in making Predictive Analytics
systems to give profound experience into
different business data of Interest this
permits to expect specific outcomes
because of a given result variable
assisting Business Leaders to justify
choices or turn to serve the association
the third one is customer sentiment
analysis utilizing supervised machine
learning Association can extract and
arrange significant pieces of data from
huge volumes of information
including context remote
this can be incredibly valuable while
acquiring a superior understanding of
blind into collaboration and can be
utilized to further develop brand
engagement efforts the fourth one is
Spam deduction spam identification is
another application of supervised
machine learning model utilizing
classification calculation companies can
prepare data sets to recognize patterns
or anomalies and new information to sort
out spam and non-spam related data
unsupervised learning is a machine
learning technique used to train the
machine learning algorithm using data
that is either unclassified or unlabeled
and allows the out on that data without
guidance unlabeled data is a designation
for pieces of data that have not been
tagged with labels identified by
characteristics Properties or
classifications
so the flow of unsupervised learning
starts with training data that has no
labels and depends on the feature Vector
the machine learning model defines the
predictive model this is tested with an
individual subset of data with its own
feature Vector here the predictive model
defines the likelihood or cluster ID or
a better representation of unlabeled
data
let's look at the difference between
unsupervised and supervised learning
supervised learning technique deals with
labeled data where the output data
patterns are known to the system
unsupervised learning works with
unlabeled data in which the output is
just based on the collection of
perceptions
supervised learning method is less
complex the unsupervised learning method
is more complex supervised learning
conducts offline analysis unsupervised
learning performs real-time analysis
the outcome of the supervised learning
technique is comparatively more accurate
and reliable
unsupervised learning generates
moderately acute but reliable results
while classification and regression are
the types of problems solved under the
supervised learning method
unsupervised learning includes
clustering and associative rule mining
problems
example and application of unsupervised
learning let's understand unsupervised
learning through an example
consider a scenario where a child had no
learning phase and is shown images
without the labels now if the child is
asked to identify if any range is a bird
or an animal he will lack the
information that can help him do so the
best he can do is come up with the
following groups based on common
patterns wings and legs for example this
explains how unsupervised Learning Works
we show a lot of data to our algorithm
and ask it to find patterns in the data
by itself
let's look at the application of
unsupervised learning
unsupervised learning can be used for
anomaly detection as well as clustering
to understand clustering let's look at a
simple real-life example a mother asks
her two children to arrange the pieces
of plain blocks the children come up
with two different groups as shown with
different similarities in the blocks
this is clustering each of our children
came up with a different type of
grouping one child grouped them based on
the shape whereas the other grouped them
based on the color there is no right
wrong way halcasters over the others
this will depend on the similarity
measure used by the mother in this case
the arrangement of child one is better
than child two if the similarity measure
chosen by the mother was that blocks
should have the same shape however the
arrangement by Child 2 is better if the
similarity measure chosen by the mother
was that blocks should have the same
color their similarity measure is
important when performing clustering
there are many different ways in which
data can be arranged in different groups
based on size shape color texture and
other complex features
anomaly detection is a cluster technique
used to identify unusual patterns that
do not conform to expected Behavior
anomaly detection has many applications
in business such as intrusion detection
system Health monitoring and fraud
detection
clustering
the method of grouping similar entities
together is called clustering the goal
of this unsupervised machine learning
method is to seek out similarities
within the data points and to Cluster
similar data points together
need for clustering let's look at the
need for clustering grouping similar
entities together helps to merge the
attributes of different clusters in
other words this gives us insight into
underlying patterns of different groups
there are a lot of applications of
grouping unlabeled data for example in
order to maximize the revenue you can
identify different groups or clusters of
customers and Market to each group in a
different way another example is
grouping books together that belong to
similar topics clustering is needed to
determine the intrinsic grouping in a
set of unlabeled data
organize data into clusters that show
internal structure of the data partition
the data points understand and extract
value from large sets of structured and
unstructured data types of clustering
there are two types of clustering
hierarchical clustering and partitional
clustering hierarchical clustering can
be agglomerative and divisive whereas
partitional clustering can be K means
and fuzzy c means a distinction among
different types of clustering is whether
the set of clusters is nested or
unnested
a partitional clustering is just a
division of the set of data objects into
non-overlapping sets or clusters such
that every data object is in just one
subset a hierarchical clustering is a
tree structure that has a set of nested
clusters
hierarchical clustering the output of
hierarchical clustering is a hierarchy
how does they hire arcticle clustering
form a hierarchy assume you are going to
create a three-layer hierarchy from six
different data nodes so first combine A
and B based on similarity and also
combine d and e based on similarity
combination of A and B is combined with
C in the similar way combination of d
and e is combined with f now combine C
and F inside one cluster when you look
at the final tree it contains all
clusters combined into a single cluster
let's understand the working of
hierarchical clustering it works in four
steps step one assign each item to its
own cluster such that if you have n
number of items you will have n number
of clusters step two merge two clusters
into a single cluster by finding the
closest pair of clusters now you will
have one cluster less step three compute
distances between the new cluster and
all old clusters step 4 repeat steps two
and three until all items are clustered
into a single cluster of size n
let's understand the distance measure in
hierarchical clustering let's look at
the different kinds of linkage in
clustering
complete linkage clustering it finds the
maximum distance between points
belonging to two different clusters
single linkage clustering it finds the
minimum possible distance between points
belonging to two different clusters mean
linkage clustering it finds all possible
pairwise distances for points belonging
to two different clusters and then
calculates the average
centroid linkage clustering it finds the
centroid of each cluster and calculates
the distance between them
what is dendrogram
it is a tree diagram frequently used to
illustrate the arrangement of the
Clusters produced by hierarchical
clustering it shows the hierarchical
relationship between objects it is most
commonly created as an output of
hierarchical clustering the main use of
a dendrogram is to work out the best way
to allocate objects to clusters the
dendrogram also shows the hierarchical
clustering of five observations and the
relationship between each of them
hierarchical clustering example
let's understand hierarchical clustering
through an example in the given example
hierarchical clustering is used to find
the distances that diff seat in
kilometers
the following Matrix traces a
hierarchical clustering of distances in
miles between different cities the
method of clustering is single link here
as you can see from the given distance
Matrix the nearest pair of objects is t
o and MI
Mi and T.O are merged into a single
cluster called Mito as Mi column has
lower values than to column Mito
consists of Mi column values
Mito column has one index with zero
value because there is no distance
between cluster Mito and Mito
to get a new distance Matrix we compute
the distance from this new cluster to
all other clusters
now the nearest pair of objects is n a
and RM these are combined into a single
cluster called narm to get a new
distance Matrix we compute the distance
from this new cluster to all other
clusters in the similar way the nearest
pair of objects is ba and narm these are
combined into a single cluster called ba
n a r m to get a new distance Matrix we
compute the distance from the new
cluster to all other clusters
similarly now the nearest pair of
objects is ba narm and f i these
combined into a single cluster called
b-a-n-a-r-m-f-i
to get a new distance Matrix we compute
the distance from this new cluster to
all other clusters
finally we merge the last two clusters
this process is summarized by the
clustering diagram on the right and the
final distance Matrix on the left why
reinforcement learning training a
machine learning model requires a lot of
data which might not always be available
to us further the data provided might
not be reliable learning from a small
subset of actions will not help expand
the vast realm of solutions that may
work for a particular problem
and you can see here we have the robot
learning to walk
very complicated setup when you're
learning how to walk and you'll start
asking questions like if I'm taking one
step forward and left what happens if I
cup a 50 pound object how does it change
how these things are very difficult to
program because there's no actual
information on it until it's actually
tried out learning from a small subset
of actions will not help expand the vast
realm of solutions that may work for a
particular problem
and we'll see here it learned how to
walk this is going to slow the growth
that technology is capable of machines
need to learn to perform actions by
themselves and not just learn off humans
and you see the objective climb a
mountain
really interesting point here is that as
human beings we can go into a very
unknown environment and we just kind of
explore and play with it
most of the models the non-reinforcement
models in computer machine learning
aren't able to do that very well there's
a couple of them that can be used or
integrated to see how it goes is what
we're talking about with reinforcement
learning so what is reinforcement
learning
reinforcement learning is a sub-branch
of machine learning that trains the
model to return an Optimum solution for
a problem by taking a sequence of
decisions by itself
consider a robot learning to go from one
place to another
the robot is given a scenario must
arrive at a solution by itself the robot
can take a different path to reach the
destination
it will know the best path by the time
taken on each side even commission and
that's really important is we're looking
for Unique Solutions we want the best
solution but you can't find it unless
you try it so we're looking at our
different systems or different model we
have supervised versus unsupervised
versus reinforcement learning and with
the supervised learning that is probably
the most controlled environment we have
a lot of different supervised learning
models whether it's linear regression
neural networks there's all kinds of
things in between decision trees the
data provided is labeled data with
output values specified and this is
important because we talk about
supervised learning you already know the
answer for all the information you
already know that the picture has a
motorcycle in it learning the outcome
for tomorrow for you know going back a
week you're looking at stock you can
already have like the graph of what the
next day looks like so you have an
answer for it
and you have labeled data which is used
you have an external supervision and
solves Problems by mapping labeled input
to known output
so very controlled
unsupervised learning and the answer
provided learning is really interesting
because it's now taking part in many
other models they start with an you can
actually insert an unsupervised learning
model
in almost either supervised or
reinforcement learning as part of the
system which is really cool
data provided is unlabeled data the
outputs are not specified
machine makes its own predictions you
need to solve as problems unlabeled data
is used no supervision solves Problems
by understanding patterns and
discovering output
so you can look at this and you can
think some of these things go with each
other they belong together so it's
looking for what connects in different
ways and there's a lot of different
algorithms that look at this when you
start getting into those there's some
really cool images that come up of what
unsupervised learning is how it can pick
out say the area of a donut one model
will see the area of the donut and the
other one will divide it into three
sections based on this location versus
what's next to it so there's a lot of
stuff that goes in with unsupervised
learning
and then we're looking at reinforcement
learning probably the biggest industry
in today's market uh in machine learning
or growing Market is very it's very
infinite stage
uh as far as how it works and what's
from its Awards and errors used to solve
reward based problems no predefined data
is used no supervision follows Trail and
error problem solving approach so again
we have a random at first you start with
a random I try this it works and this is
my reward doesn't work very well maybe
or maybe it doesn't even get you where
you're trying to get it to do and you
get your reward back and then it looks
at that and says well let's try
something else and it starts to play
with these different things finding the
best route
so let's take a look at important terms
in today's reinforcement model
and this has become pretty standardized
over the last few years so these are
really good to know we have the agent
agent is the model that is being trained
via reinforcement learning so this is
your actual entity
that has however we're doing I'm using a
neural network or a table or what in
thereof this is the actual agent that
you're using this is the model
and you have your environment the
training situation that the model must
optimize to is called its environment
and you can see here I guess we have a
robot who's trying to get a chest full
of gyms or whatever and that's the
output and then you have your action
this is all possible steps that can be
taken by the model and it picks one
action and you can see here that's
picked three different routes to get to
the chest of diamonds and gems
we have a state the current position
condition returned by the model
and you could look at this uh if you're
playing like a video game this is the
screen you're looking at so when you go
back here on the environment whole game
board so if you're playing one of those
Mobius games
you might have the whole game board
going on but then you have your current
position where are you on that game
board what's around that what's around
you
um if you were talking about a robot the
environment might be moving around the
yard where it is in the yard and what it
can see what input it has in that
location that would be the current
position condition returned by the model
and then the reward to help the model
move in the right direction it is
rewarded points are given to it to
appraise some kind of action so yeah you
did good or if didn't do as good trying
to maximize the reward and have the best
reward possible
and then policy policy determines how an
agent will behave at any time it
actually between action and present
state
this is part of the model what is your
action that you're you're going to take
what's the policy you're using put for
eight since they separate uh policy as
its own entity
is that you usually have a prediction
um of different options and then the
policy well how am I going to pick the
best based on those predictions I'm
going to guess at different options
and we'll actually weigh those options
in and find the best option we think
will work
so it's a little tricky but the policy
thing is actually pretty cool how it
works let's go ahead and take a look at
a reinforcement learning example and
just in looking at this we're going to
take a look consider what a dog that we
want to train so the dog would be like
the agent so you have your your puppy or
whatever and then your environment is
going to be the whole house or whatever
it is or where you're training them and
then you have an action we want to teach
the dog to fetch
so action equals fetching
and then we have a little biscuits we
can get the dog to perform various
actions by offering an incentive to dog
get a war the dog will follow a policy
to maximize this reward and hence will
follow every command and might even
learn new actions like begging by itself
so yeah you know so we started off with
fetching it goes oh I get a biscuit for
that it tries something else you get a
handshake or begging or something like
that and goes oh this is also reward
based and so it kind of explores things
to find out what will bring it is
biscuit
and that's very much like how reinforced
model goes is it looks for different
rewards how do I find can I try
different things and find a reward that
works
the dog also will want to run around and
play an explore its environment uh this
quality of models called exploration so
there's a little Randomness going on in
Exploration
it explores new parts of the house
climbing on the sofa doesn't get a
reward in fact it usually gets kicked
off the sofa
so let's talk a little bit of markov's
decision process
is a reinforcement learning policy used
to map a current state to an action
where the agent continuously interacts
with the environment to produce new
Solutions and receive rewards and you'll
see here's all of our different uh
vocabulary we just went over we have a
reward our state or agent our
environment interaction and so even
though the environment kind of contains
everything
that you really when you're actually
writing the program your environment's
going to put out a reward and state that
goes into the agent uh the agent then
looks at this state or it looks at the
reward usually um first and it says okay
I got rewarded for whatever I just did
or it didn't get rewarded
and it looks at the state and then it
comes back and if you remember from
policy the policy comes in and then we
have a reward the policy is that part
that's connected at the bottom
and so it looks at that policy and it
says hey what's a good act probably be
similar to what I did or uh sometimes
they're completely random but what's a
good action that's going to bring me a
different reward
so taking the time to just understand
these different pieces as they go
is pretty important in most of the
models today and so a lot of them
actually have templates based on this
you can pull in and start using
um pretty straightforward as far as once
you start seeing how it works you can
see your environment since it says hey
this is what the agent did this if
you're a character in a game this
happened and it shoots out a reward in a
state the agent looks at the reward
looks at the new state and then takes a
little guess and says I'm going to try
this action and then that action goes
back into the environment it affects the
environment the environment then changes
depending on what the action was and
then it has a new state and a new reward
that goes back to the agent so in the
diagram Sean we need to find the
shortest path between node A and D each
path has a reward associated with it and
the path with a maximum reward is what
we want to choose
the node ABCD denote the nodes to travel
from node A to B is an action reward is
the cost of each path and policy is each
path taken and you can see here a can go
to B
or a can go to C right off the bat or it
can go right to D
and if explored all three of these you
would find that a going to D was a zero
reward a going to C and D would generate
a different reward
or you could go a c b d there's a lot of
options here and so when we start
looking at this diagram you start to
realize
that even though uh today's reinforced
learning models do really good at
finding an answer they end up trying
almost all the different directions you
see and so they take up a lot of work uh
or a lot of processing time for
reinforcement learning they're right now
in their infant stage and they're really
good at solving simple problems and
we'll take a look at one of those in
just a minute in the tic-tac-toe game
but you can see here once it's gone
through these and it's explored it's
going to find the ACD is the best reward
it gets a full 30 points for it
and computer programming an algorithm is
a set of well-defined instruction to
solve a particular problem it takes a
bunch of information sources and deliver
the ideal result most of us must be
using a Snapchat to apply filters on
your faces while making videos or
capturing photographs but do you know
how does Snapchat denies your face while
capturing videos or photographs and put
filters on it even if there are multiple
faces it applies filter only this became
possible with the help of phase
recognition technique which uses machine
learning algorithms to detect phases and
apply required filters on them so this
is the basic idea of how an algorithms
work let's move ahead in this video and
we will now discuss how an algorithm
work in machine learning but before that
let's go through what is machine
learning
machine learning is a subpart of
artificial intelligence the art of
making computers learn and act like
humans by feeding data and make
predictions based on experience as we
saw in previous example when the data
that is how far is the nearest fuel
station comes in the machine or in our
case CD immediately start analyzing data
and machine accurately makes prediction
and decision based on given data now
that we have an understanding of what
machine learning is let's move forward
and discuss different types of machine
learning
machine learning is classified
supervised learning unsupervised
learning reinforcement learning there
are two sort of problems in supervised
learning classification and regression
certain types of machine learning
algorithms fall under the
classifications are this is an algorithm
KN algorithm logistic algorithms name
base algorithm support Vector machine
algorithm svm however in regression
types of machine learning algorithms are
linear regression regression trees
non-linear regression and Bayesian
linear regression
you know talking about unsupervised
learning there are two sorts of problems
in unsupervised learning clustering and
Association algorithms that fall under
clustering problems include k-means
clustering algorithms principal
component analysis algorithms however
algorithms that fall under Association
problem are a priority algorithms FP
growth algorithms and reinforcement
learning there are two types positive
reinforcement negative reinforcement
reinforcement learning algorithms are
mainly used in AI applications and
gaming applications
there are certain types of problems
which force under reinforcement learning
are Q learning State action reward State
action s-a-r-s-a algorithms if you
neural network and Markov decision
process after discussing what machine
learning is and its side let's move
forward to see how algorithm work in
machine learning
everyone knows the algorithm is a
step-by-step process to approach a
particular problem there are numerous
examples of algorithms from figuring out
sets of number to finding routes through
maps to showing data on a screen let's
understand this by using an example
every algorithm is built on inputs and
outputs Google search algorithm is no
different the input is the search field
and the output is the page of its result
that appears when you enter a particular
phrase or keyword also known as serp or
search engine result page
Google has a search algorithm so it can
sort results from various website and
provides the users the best result
when you start a search you will see the
search box will attempt to guess what
you are looking for in order to better
understand what the user is looking for
the algorithm is trying to gather as
many as suggestions from them as
possible
the results from the search field that
best matches the query will be ranked
the choose fit website will Rank and in
what position using more than 200
attacking Wheels now let's take an
example of coding program and see how
the algorithm works
here we will use a case of computer
program wherein we want to print the
multiplication table of any number let's
take two the algorithm start here and
then it assign a value to a variable the
variable I is having an initial value of
1. the system will read the number the
number in case is 2. now the system has
a condition a condition can now either
be true or false if the value of I
reaches 11 then the loop will end
otherwise value of I will multiply by
the number
the initial value of I is 1 so for the
first time the system output will be 2.
now value of I will be increased by 1.
according to the loop condition
the system will then move back and check
for the condition again
the new value of I is 2. which is still
less than 11 the system will again print
2 into Y which is 2 into 2 on this
screen
the new output result will be 4. the
system will keep following the same
procedure repeatedly until the value of
I becomes 11. once the value of I
becomes 11 then only the algorithm will
terminate after discussing how an
algorithm work let's move forward and
see some popular machine learning
algorithms
some popular machine learning algorithms
are
first one is linear regression algorithm
second one is logistic regression
algorithm
and the third one is decision tree
and the fourth one is support Vector
machine algorithm svm
and the fifth one is KNN K nearest
neighbor algorithms and the sixth one is
K means clustering algorithms the and
the seventh one is random Forest
algorithms and the last but not the
least algorithm is a priority algorithms
let's go through them in detail one by
one
linear depression is one of the most
famous and straightforward machine
learning algorithms utilized for
predictive analysis linear regression
show the linear connection between the
dependent and independent factors
the equation of line is y equals to MX
plus b here y stand for this response
variable or a dependent variable whereas
X is for the Predator variable or an
independent variable it attempts best to
fit line between the dependent and
independent variables and this best bit
line is known as line of regression or
regression line
let's take a real application example in
predicting consumer Behavior businesses
use the linear regression to forecast
things like how much a client is likely
to spend
things like targeted marketing and
product development May benefit from
this
Walmart for instance use linear
regression to forecast which good would
be in high demand Across the Nation
moving forward let's see types of linear
regression
there are two types of linear regression
algorithm
the first one is simple linear
regression and the second one is
multiple linear regression
in simple linear regression if an
independent variable is utilized to
forecast the worth of a mathematical
dependent variable then at that point
such a linear regression algorithm is
called Simple linear regression the
equation of line will be y equals to A 0
plus a 1 X
and the second one is multiple linear
regression if the dependent variables
declines on the Y and that if
independent variable on the X
then such a relationship is known as
negative linear relationship the line of
equation will be minus of a 0 plus a 1 X
moving forward let's see logistic linear
regression
logistic regression is the supervised
machine learning algorithm utilized to
anticipate all the categorical factors
or discrete values it could be very well
used for the grouping issues in machine
learning and the result of the logistic
regression can be either yes or no 0 or
1 man or woman and so on it gives the
values which lies between 0 and 1. for
example a credit card business is
interested in knowing whether the
transaction amount and the credit score
have an impact on the probability that a
particular transaction would be
fraudulent the business can use Logitech
redirection to determine how these two
Predator values can relate the
probability that a transaction is
fraudulent
this response variable in the model has
two possible outcomes
first one is the transaction is
shortland and the second one is the
transaction is not fault line
in logistic regression rather than
fitting a regression line we fit an S
form logistic capability which predicts
two greatest value 0 or 1. the logistic
regression equation can be calculated
from linear regression equation the
steps to get logistic regression
equations are the equation of straight
line can be written as y equals to b0
plus B1 X1 plus b 2 x 2 till b n x n in
logistic regression y can be between 0
and 1 only so for that let's divide the
above equation by 1 minus y then the
equation will be y upon 1 minus y that
is 0 for y 0 and Infinity for y equals
to 1 but range between minus infinity to
plus infinity then we have to take the
logarithm of equation and now it will
become log of Y upon 1 minus y equals to
b0 plus b 1 x 1 plus B2 X2 so on till b
n x n let's move forward and see types
of logistic regression
there are three types of logitative
regression that can be classified first
one is binomial in binomial logistic
regression there can be only two
possible types of dependent variables
like yes or no password man woman and
many more and the second one is
multinomial in multinomial logistic
regression there can be three or more
possible unordered ways of dependent
variable such as horse cow and sheep and
the last one is ordinal inordinary
logistic regression there can be three
or more possible ordered ways of
dependent variable such as small medium
or large moving forward let's see
decision trees in detail
a decision tree is a tree structured
classifier that could be used for
classification and regression a decision
tree is a tree in which each non-leaf
node is assigned to an attribute
additionally each are contained one of
the available values for its parent node
which is associated with each Leaf node
that is the node from where the arc is
directed let's see some decision tree
terminology
first one is root that contains the
entire data set the next one is node a
test for the data of a certain attribute
and the third one is branch which
connect the node to internal node or the
internal node to Leaf node and the
fourth one is leaf node the terminal
node that predicts the outcome let's
move forward and see decision tree
algorithms the first one is select the
best attribute to use the current node
in the tree the second one is for each
possible values select the attributes
the third one is partition the examples
using the possible values of this
attribute and assign these disjoint
subset or the example to the appropriate
child node recursively generate each
child node until ideally all examples
for a node have the same label like
class moving forward let's understand
this recently for building a decision
tree Step One is Select an attribute
then split the data into its children in
a tree continue splitting with available
attributes
and keep splitting until late node are
pure like only one class remains a
maximum depth is a performance metric is
achieved let's move forward and see svm
algorithm support Vector machine
algorithms
a support Vector machine is a well-known
supervised machine learning model it is
utilized for both information
classification and regression
it is regularly utilized for the
grouping issues we can involve it in
different life care system and we can
involve it in typically happy or sad
look Arrangements we can involve it in
filters if we make specific Loops it
would add the particular filter
according to the expression the scope of
articulation lies between happy and sad
support Vector machine helps them to
recognize and return characters use
widely like checks continue to which a
significant part of the majority of
non-cash transaction and are frequently
written by the pupil
the current check processing system in
many developing nations involves a bank
employee to read and manually enter the
information in a check while also
verifying the data like signature and
date
a handwritten text recognition system
can reduce expenses and labor hours
because a bank must handle several
checks each day
moving forward let's see the algorithm
of svm
the objective of support Vector machine
is to make the best line or Choice limit
that can isolate and dimensional space
into classes so we can undoubtedly put
the new data of interest in the right
category later on this best decision
boundary is known as a hyperplate let's
move forward and see types of support
Vector machine support Vector machine
can be of two types first one is linear
svm second one is non-linear SPM let's
move forward and see linear sphere
linear svm is utilized for linearly
detachable information
which implies if a data set can be
ordered into two classes by utilizes a
straight line then such information are
named linearly separable information and
a classifier is utilized called linear
SPM classifier
moving forward let's see non-linear svm
non-linear SPM is utilized for
non-dietly isolated information and that
implies in the event that a data set
can't be categorized by utilizing a
straight line such information is named
non-directed information
and the classifier utilize is called a
non-linear SPM classifier moving forward
let's see k n algorithm in detail
Canon is a supervised learning technique
Canon classifies new data into our
targeted classes depending on the
features of its neighboring points and
also be used for the regression problems
it is an instance based learning
algorithm and a bit lazy learning
algorithm k n calculation stores every
one of its accessible information and
orders another information Point based
on the likeliness this means that when
new data information appears it usually
tends to the successfully categorized
into a good suit classes using the k n
algorithm let's imagine we have an image
of animal that resembles a cow or Ox
however here we are not sure if it is a
cow or Ox as k n method is based on a
likeness Matrix it will identify the
properties of new data that are related
to the image of cow or ox and based on
those quality it will classify the data
is belonging to either cow or Ox group
moving forward let's see how does CNN
work
the steps to implement k n algorithms
are step one decide on the neighbor's K
numbers Step 2 calculate the euclidean
distance between K Neighbors in step 2.
third one is based on the determined
nuclear distance select the K closest
neighbors step 4 is count the numbers of
data points in each category between
these connectors step 5 assign the fresh
data points in the category where the
highest neighbors count and then k n
model is ready
Let's see we need to add a new data
point to the vital category at first we
will decide on the numbers of neighbors
therefore we will pick k equals to 5.
then the euclidean distance between the
data points and then can be determined
the distance between two points known as
the euclidean distance can be determined
by under root of X2 minus X when the
whole square plus Y2 minus y1 whole
Square
then we determine the closest neighbors
by calculating the equivalent distance
there are three closest Neighbors in
category a and two closest neighbor in
category B
this new data point Must Fall with
category a because as we can see its
three closest neighbors are also from
group a after understanding k n
algorithm let's move forward and see
k-means algorithms in detail
the game means in the cluster falls
under that his announce provides
learning algorithm it is used to address
machine learning clustering problems and
utilize to tackle the grouping issues in
machine learning
it permits us to Bunch the information
into various Gatherings it is a helpful
method for finding the classification of
groups in the unlabeled data set without
the requirement of any training this
k-means algorithm groups the data into
similar classes let's see some
application of k-means clustering let's
see some applications of k-means
clustering diagnostic system the medical
profession uses k-means costing in
creating smarter medical decision
support system especially in the
treatment of lever alignments the second
one is search engines clustering forms a
backbone of search engine when a search
engine is performed the search result
need to be grouped and the search
engines very open use clustering to do
this moving forward let's see how
k-means algorithm works
his steps to implement k-means
algorithms are step one select the
number key to set the number of clusters
Step 2 select a random K points or
centroid step 3 assign each data point
the closest centroid data forms to
predefined K cluster step 4 determine
the variance and a certain new Gravity
points for each cluster step 5 repeat
the third step this means G allocating
each data point to the new closest
centroid cluster step 6 if I
reassignment occurs go to step 4
otherwise go to exit step 7 the model is
ready to use
so now we have a clear understanding of
how k-means algorithm work let's move
forward to see the graphical
representation of k-means algorithm
consider that there are two variables M1
and M2 this is a scatter plot of these
two variables along the X and Y axis we
should accept the number of K of punches
that is k equals to 2 to recognize the
data set and to place them into various
groups it implies here we will attempt
to Bunch these data set into two unique
groups people really want to pick an
irregular key point or centroid to frame
this group
these centroids can be either the focus
of the data set or some of other points
thus here we are choosing under two
points as cables which are not the piece
of our data set
we will assign every data of interest in
this scatter plot to the nearest K point
or centroid we will register it by
applying some math that we consider to
find the distance between two points
that is euclidean distance thus we will
draw a median between both the centroids
from the graph the left half of the line
are close points to the right and the K1
centroid green is near the orange
centroid we should variety them as green
and orange for Clear representation as
the need might arise to track down the
nearest group we will repeat the cycle
by picking another centroid
to pick the new centroid we will figure
out the center point of gravity of the
centroid and will track down new
centroids then we will reassign every
piece of information to highlight new
centroid for this we will repeat a
similar course of tracking down a middle
line the middle will be like as seen in
the picture one orange point is on the
left half of the line and two green
points are on the right thus these three
points will be appointed to the new
centroids as reassignment has occurred
we will again go to step 4 tracking down
new centroids or k points we will repeat
the cycle by tracking down the center
point of gravity of centroid so the new
centroids will be displayed as like this
we now have new centroid so once more
defined the middle boundary and reassign
the data of Interest by this graph there
are no unique pieces of information on
one of the other side of the line
implying our model is shaped by the
previous graph there are no unique
pieces of information on one or the
other line implying our model is shaped
as our k-means model is ready and the
two plus groups will be displayed as
like these now we have a clear
understanding of how k-means clustering
algorithm works now let's move forward
to understand random Forest algorithm
random Forest is an adaptable simple to
utilize machine learning algorithm that
produces even without the hyper boundary
tuning an extraordinary outcome more
often than not it is likewise quite
possibly the most utilized algorithm
because of its effortness and variety
like it tend to be utilized for both
grouping and classification tasks random
Forest is a classifier that contains
various Choice trees on different
subsets of the given data set and takes
the normal to work on the present
exactness of the data set instead of
depending on the choice tree the random
Forest takes the forecast from each tree
and in light of the larger part of
boards of expectation it predicts the
final result
now let's move forward and see how does
random Forest work
we should see the random forest in order
since the arrangement is now and again
thought to be the structured block of
machine learning this is what a random
Forest would look like with two trees
the random Forest has a similar
hypermeter to their decision tree or a
paging classifier luckily there is a
compelling reason need to consolidate a
decision trade with a badging classifier
since you can undoubtedly utilize the
classified classes of random queries
with random Forest you can likewise
manage tasks using the algorithm
regression random forests add extra
arbitness to the model while deploying
the trees rather than looking for the
main element while parting a node
it looks to the best component among an
irregular subset of highlights these
outcomes in a wide variety often result
in a superior model
subsequently in a random Forest just a
random subset of the element is thought
about the algorithms you might make
trees more random by involving random
edges for each component instead of
looking for the most ideal limits like a
typical Choice Traders
let's move forward and see some
application of random Forest algorithms
random Forest is involved at work by
researchers in numerous Ventures
including banking stock exchanging
medication and many more it is utilized
to predict things which assist these
businesses with running productively
like client activity patient history and
safety in banking random Forest is used
to identify clients who are more likely
to pay back their debts on schedule
additionally it is utilized to forecast
who will make more frequent use of Bank
Services even fraud detection uses it
the robin node of algorithms indeed
random Forest is a tool used by stock
Trader to forecast future stock Behavior
retail businesses utilize it to make
product recommendation and forecast
client satisfaction random Forex can be
used in healthcare industry to examine a
patient medical history and detect
disorders random Forest is a tool used
by pharmaceutical expert to determine
the ideal mix of ingredients in
treatment or to forecast drug
sensitivity by seeing application of
random Forest algorithm let's move
forward and see some difference between
decision trees and random Forest
let's see the difference between random
forest and decision tree the first one
is
while building a random Forest the
number of rows is selected randomly in
decision trees it builds several
decision trees and find out the output
the second one is it combines two or
more decision trees together in decision
trees whereas the decision is a
collection of variables or data sets or
attributes the third one is it gives
accurate results whereas it gets less
accurate results the fourth one is by
using random Forest it reduces the
chance of overlifting whereas decision
trees it has the possibility of
overlifting the fifth one is random
Forest is more complicated to
interpreters whereas the decision tree
is simple it is easy to read and
understand
after seeing what is random Forest how
it works let's move forward to see a
primary algorithm in detail
the Apparently algorithm utilize
standard item sets to create affiliation
rules and is intended to chip away the
information basis containing exchanges
with the assistance of these application
rules it decide how firmly or feebly two
objects are associated
this algorithm utilize a breakfast
search and history to work out the items
at Association effectively
it is the iterative interaction for
finding out the successive item set from
the huge data set
let's move forward and see steps for a
priority algorithms the steps for a
priority algorithms are Step One is
establish minimal support and confidence
for item set in the transactional
database the second one is take all
transaction supports with a greater
support value the minimum or chosen
support value in Step 2. the third one
is track down all the rules in these
subsets with confidence value greater
than the threshold value the fourth one
is arrange the rules to lower the lift
at last we will see some advantages and
disadvantages of a priority algorithm
the advantages of a priority algorithms
are easy to understand an algorithm and
the second one is the join and prune
steps of the algorithms can be easily
implemented on the large data set the
disadvantages of a priority algorithms
are they are priority algorithms work
slowly as compared to the other
algorithm and the second one is the a
priority algorithms times and space
complexity are o of 2D which is very low
compared to the other ones
machine learning has improved our lives
in a number of wonderful ways today
let's talk about some of these I'm Rahul
from Simply learn and these are the top
10 applications of machine learning
first let's talk about virtual personal
assistance Google Assistant Alexa
Cortana and Siri now we've all used one
of these at least at some point in our
lives now these help improve our lives
in a great number of ways for example
you could tell them to call someone you
could tell them to play some music you
could tell them to even schedule an
appointment so how do these things
actually work first they record whatever
you're saying send it over to a server
which is usually in a cloud decode it
with the help of machine learning and
neural networks and then provide you
with an output so if you ever noticed
that these systems don't work very well
without the internet that's because the
server couldn't be contacted next let's
talk about traffic predictions now say I
wanted to travel from Buckingham Palace
to Lord's cricket ground the first thing
I would probably do is to get on Google
Maps so search it
and let's put it here
so here we have the path you should take
to get a large cricket ground now here
the map is a combination of red yellow
and blue now the blue regions signify a
clear road that is you won't encounter
traffic there yellow indicate that they
are slightly congested and red means
they are heavily congested so let's look
at the map a different version of the
same map and here as I told you before
red means heavily congested yellow means
slow moving and blue means clear
so how exactly is Google able to tell
you that the traffic is clear slow
moving or heavily congested so this is
the help of machine learning and with
the help of two important measures first
is the average time that's taken on
specific days at specific times on that
route the second one is the real-time
location data of vehicles from Google
Maps and with the help of sensors some
of the other popular map services are
Bing Maps maps.me and here we go next up
we have social media personalization so
say I want to buy a drone and I'm on
Amazon and I want to buy a DJI mavic Pro
the thing is it's close to one lap so I
don't want to buy it right now but the
next time I'm on Facebook I'll see an
advertisement for the product next time
I'm on YouTube I'll see an advertisement
even on Instagram I'll see an
advertisement so here with the help of
machine learning Google has understood
that I'm interested in this particular
product hence it's targeting me with
these advertisements this is also with
the help of machine learning let's talk
about email spam filtering now this is a
spam that's in my inbox now how does
Gmail know what spam and what's not spam
so Gmail has an entire collection of
emails which have already been labeled
as spam or not spam so after analyzing
this data Gmail is able to find some
characteristics like the word lottery or
winner from then on any new email that
comes to your inbox goes through a few
spam filters to decide whether it's spam
or not now some of the popular spam
filters that Gmail uses is content
filters header filters General Blacklist
filters and so on next we have online
fraud detection now there are several
ways that online fraud can take place
for example there's identity theft where
they steal your identity fake accounts
where these accounts only last for how
long the transaction takes place and
stop existing after that and man in the
middle attacks where they steal your
money while the transaction is taking
place the feed forward neural network
helps determine whether a transaction is
genuine or fraudulent so what happens
with feed forward neural networks are
that the outputs are converted into hash
values and these values become the
inputs for the next round so for every
real transaction that takes place
there's a specific pattern a fraudulent
transaction would stand out because of
the significant changes that it would
cause with the hash values Stock Market
trading machine learning is used
extensively when it comes to Stock
Market trading now you have stock market
indices like nikai they use long
short-term memory neural networks now
these are used to classify process and
predict data when there are time lags of
unknown size and duration now this is
used to predict stock market trends
assistive Medical Technology now medical
technology has been innovated with the
help of machine learning diagnosing
diseases has been easier from which we
can create 3D models that can predict
where exactly there are lesions in the
brain it works just as well for brain
tumors and Ice chemic stock lesions they
can also be used in fetal Imaging and
cardiac analysis now some of the medical
fields that machine learning will help
assist in is disease identification
personalized treatment drug Discovery
clinical research and radiology and
finally we have automatic translation
now say you're in a foreign country and
you see Billboards and signs that you
don't understand that's where automatic
translation comes of help now how does
automatic translation actually work the
technology behind it is the same as the
sequence of sequence learning which is
the same thing that's used with chatbots
here the image recognition happens using
convolutional neural networks and the
text is identified using optical
character recognition furthermore the
sequential sequence algorithm is also
used to translate the text from one
language to the other
a collection of python bindings called
opencv
python was created to address issue with
the computer vision
python is general purpose programming
language created by Judo Von Rasam that
quickly gained popularity largely due to
its ease of use and readable code the
programmer can express Concept in less
code without sacrificing readability
numpy a highly efficient library for
numerical operation with a Matlab like
syntax is used by opencv python numpy
arrays are translated into and out of
all opencv array forms additionally this
make it simpler to interact with other
numpy using libraries like scipy and
matplotlib after understanding what is
opencv let's move forward and see what
phase detection is so what is Phase
detection
phase detection also known as facial
detection is a computer technology that
uses artificial intelligence to find and
recognize human faces in digital
photographs
Fair Direction technology can be enabled
real-time surveillance and tracking of
people in various Industries such as
security Biometrics law enforcement
entertainment and personal safety
from basic computer vision method to
developments in machine learning to
increasingly use complex artificial
neural network and related Technologies
phase detection has advanced leading or
to ongoing performance increases
it now serves as the foundation from
some crucial applications such as face
tracking phase analysis face recognition
the application ability to perform
sequential tasks subsequently impacts
the phase Direction
so dear Leonard if you want to upskill
your AI and machine learning skills so
give a chance to Simply land
professional certificate program in Ai
and machine learning which comes with
completion certificate and in-depth
knowledge of AI and machine learning
check this course detail from the
description box below
so here is one question for you guys I
will give you exactly one minute for
this you can comment or give your answer
in the chat section so I can see if the
answer is given by you are right or
wrong
so the question is
which of the following function is a
built-in function in Python
factorial
print
seed
sqrt
so I am starting the timer of one minute
just type your answer in the comment
section or in the chat section please do
let me know your answers
so I'm starting the timer of one minute
each of the following function is a
built-in function in Python factorial
print seed sqrt let us know your answer
in the comment section below
I kindly ask that everyone take part in
this session
which of the following function is a
built-in function in Python
30 seconds more
factorial print seed sqrt
please let me know your answer in the
comment section below
20 seconds remaining
each of the following function is a
built-in function in Python
10 seconds more
please let us know your answer in the
comment section below
so after the allotted time has passed
Those Who provided the current response
will receive a response and those Who
provided the incorrect response will
receive one
so now let's move to our programming
part to create to write a command to
open jupyter notebook so here we will
write Jupiter
notebook
press enter
so this is the landing page of Jupiter
notebook and here you have to select new
python file
so this is how the Jupiter notebook UI
looks like so at first we will import
some major libraries of python which
will help us in creating a phase
detection system
so first let me rename this
paste
Direction
first we will import import
CV2
press enter then import another Library
import numpy
as NP
and the third one is Major One Import
face
recognition
as
fr
then press enter
so CV means capturing video the CV2
function is an opencv can read video
video capture by using pass 0 function
parameter we can access our webcam we
may pass as rtsp URL in the function
parameter to capture the CCTV footage
which is quite helpful for video
analysis
and another one is numpy numpy is a
python Library used for working with the
arrays it also has function for working
in the domain of lineal algebra and
matrices it is an open source project
you can use it freely numpy stands for
numerical python
and the third one is Phase recognition
phase recognition and manipulation using
python or the command line the easiest
facial recognition library in the world
built using Cutting Edge face
recognition technology from dlib
developed using deep learning
so moving forwards let's import our
video capture device so for that we have
to write Here video
underscore capture this is our variable
name
equals to
CV2 Dot
video
capture
and we have to pass here zero
then press enter
okay here we
should be capital
so the video capture function from
opencv is used to interact with the
cameras what we can do is video can be
read shown and saved display the image
that the camera captured
so moving forward let me import my image
for the further detection process okay
so
image equals to
FR dot load
underscore image
underscore file
then
image name or image path boy
dot jpg
press enter
using load image file we can import
image file to our detection system so
moving forward let's set encoding for
the image okay so I will write here
image underscore phase underscore
encoding
equals to
FR Dot
face
encodings
and image
than zero
press enter
yeah so face encoding basically uses 128
computer generated measure to represent
the phase similar encoding would be
present in two images of the same person
while being completely different in two
images of two distinct people
so moving forward let's do let me write
first
I will write here known
encodings
equals to
image
phase
coding
okay
then press enter
then known
phase
names
equals to
then here I have to put my name so I
will write
Bank
okay then press enter
so what I did is I assigned known page
encodings to my image face encoding so
what will happen if image matches to my
face then it will print my name and for
the rest we will add name unknown okay
so let me add the function now for phase
detection system
so let me write the full code for it
first then I will explain you line wise
okay
so just stay tuned with me
I will write here
so I will add while
okay true
okay so r e t comma frame I will explain
you line wise line don't worry equals to
then video
capture
dot read
and RGB
underscore frame
was to
frame
then colon
comma then again colon comma then two
colon
then minus 1.
okay
yeah
so here I will write FC underscore
locations
equals to FR dot face
underscore locations
RGB
underscore frame
write here FC FC is for basically face
encodings
plus two fr
dot face
underscore encodings
and RGB
underscore frame
comma FC underscore
locations
okay
so for
top
comma right comma
bottom
left
okay then I have to write your face
the score encoding
comma face underscore encoding this is
that was encodings this is encoding
okay so before that I will write here
Okay so
I have to write here encoding
in zip
okay then here I have to write
FC underscore
locations locations
okay
then comma then face encodings
colon
then press enter
so here I have to write matches
yeah
matches equals to FR dot compare
faces
then known
the score phase
the score encodings
comma
face underscore encoding
okay
so
it
so what if
the image will not match so I have to
give the name equals so
unknown
then we will write face distances
plus 2
FR dot phase
underscore distances
underscore encodings
comma
paste
School encoding
then I will write match underscore index
equals to NP Dot
AR
G min
okay then I will write here FC
underscore distances
yeah
then moving forward
I have lied if
matches
then match underscore
index
okay then colon
the name
equals to
known underscore phase
underscore names
then
match underscore index
and I have to write here CV2
Dot rectangle
and frame
comma
comma top
comma right
to give another bracket here
comma
bottom
that comma
0 comma 0 comma 255
again comma then 2 for the Border
so then CV2 dot rectangle
yeah
oh Mom then again
left comma
bottom
and minus
35.
okay
so then I will write
comma bottom
comma
then again
0 comma 0 comma 255
then CV2 dot f i l l e d field
okay
F should be capital
yeah
so then we will set font equals to
CV2
Dot
font
okay
the score
underscore
simplex
okay
so then I have to write here
CV2
dot put
text
name
comma name
comma
left
six
comma bottom
minus six
okay then comma point
comma
1.0 then
again one comma then we have to set
location like 255
oh my 255
comma 255
then comma
1.
okay
and here I have to write CV2
dot image show I am show
then like
simply learn
is detection
comma frame
and if
CV2 Dot
weight key
is 1
and
like 0 x
f
capital f f equals to equals to
ORD then
quit
and here I will write break
I will write video
underscore capture
dot release
TV2
dot destroy
all
windows
okay yeah
so let me explain you
so in general rad is a Boolean value
that indicates whether or not there was
a even a return each frame that is
written is at the same frame if there is
no frame you will receive none rather
than an error
in opencv reading and writing videos and
reading and writing images are quite
similar a video is nothing more than a
collection of pictures often known as
frames
so to draw a rectangle around the face
that was discovered we utilize the
opencv rectangle the rectangle function
we can draw the rectangle by using the
points or Corners position that the
phase location
and
is encoding this a face encoding this
one
so a face encoding basically uses 128
computer generated measures to represent
the phase similar encoding what we
present in two images of the same person
while being completely different in two
images of two distinct people
so this there is a use compare phase
so compare phase is used to compare my
face to uploaded image one okay if it
matches it will print my name otherwise
we have given a known here
so the numpy argr
this one
but it went this numpy ARG min
so the number ARG Min method delivers
the indexes of the arrays minimum
element along each axis return an array
of array indices with the same shape of
the array
so this font that is yeah
font Hershey simplex
is normal size of sans serif font okay
so put text put text is used to put the
text on the frame like my name or
unknown
so in order to display an image in a
window we use the IM show this one
the Samsung function
okay so the window adjust itself to the
size of image parameters window name a
string that identifies the window in
which the displayed image will appear
okay
so until a key is pressed wait key zero
this one okay so until a key is pressed
wait key zero will will keep the window
open it is suitable for image display
and wait key one
I write here wait key one so wait key
one will show a frame for one Ms before
closing the display on its own
so after the script has ended users can
close or remove all the windows use the
python
like using destroy all function function
okay you would use the function if you
wanted to close a window while it was
open in numerous windows at once
so let's see our phase detection system
is working or not so let me close this
person on your screen first okay
so let me close this first
let me run this
now so here you can see this pop-up and
I will open so here you can see my name
is correctly printing
okay
so
like I have uploaded my image it's
directing correctly okay
so like what if I show uh one more image
so here you can see this is my card
so it is
detecting properly
yeah
so what if I will show like another guy
image so
from my mobile
so here you can see
it is spring unknown in
Messi's photo
yeah
so what if if I will write here like uh
one of the
other image this random.jpg then it
should print unknown for me also okay
then I will run it again
okay it's working
has come
so here you can see it is now printing
unknown because like I have uploaded
that another random image here so it is
importing
okay so it is printing unknown here
so here you can see like it's spinning
unknown for me also
next to speech is an API cloud service
that enables you to turn return text
into real sounding audio in a range of
languages and voices
by connecting with people in their own
language you can give your business a
voice an enhanced customer experience
and engagement
increasingly accessibility of users of
diverse abilities offering audio
alternatives to prevent driving while
distracted or automating customer
service interaction to reduce hold items
so let's move to our programming part to
create a text to speech converter
application using python
so first we will open command prompt to
write command to open Jupiter notebook
so here we will write Jupiter
notebook
to open Jupiter notebook
press enter
so this is the landing page of Jupiter
notebook and select open new python file
so this is how the Jupiter UI looks like
so at first we will import some major
libraries of python which will help us
in creating UI and to convert text to
speech so the first one is
import
sorry import
EK enter
as PK
so TK enter is also known as TK
interface the default python interface
for TCL TK GUI toolkit is the TK enter
package or ticker interface
majority of Unix System including Mac OS
as well as Windows machine support TK
and TK enter
TK enter which is part of all common
python distribution is The Binding legal
method for creating graphical user
interface GUI in Python it is the only
framework included in the python
standard library in fact
so the next one is
first we will write here
import
sorry
from
TK enter
port
so from
TK enter
port
I
I love
to file dialog TK enter provides a
number of built-in methods and class
Library function to create application
components and user actionable elements
one of the TK enter modules called file
dialog offers classes and Library
functions for making windows for
selecting files and dictionaries
when you need to request that a user
browser file or directory on the system
you can use file dialog
so the next one is
from
TK enter
Dot ttk
import
combo box
combo box combines an entry field and a
list box
one of the TK intervisits it has down
arrow to choose from a menu of
possibilities it dates consumer and
choosing from the list of available
options a pop-up of a scrolling list box
is displayed down the entry field when
user clicks on the drop down arrow on
the entry field only when option from
the list box is selected will the select
option be shown in the enter field
so one is
it is one of the major One Import
ey
X
X3
okay
so a python text to speech conversion
library is called pyts X3
it is compatible with python 2 and 3 and
works offline unlike competing libraries
to obtain a reference to a pytx library
engine instance an application called
the pytic X3 init Factory method it is a
very user-friendly program that turns
type text to a speech
is Happy 5 for windows program offers
two voices that the pytd sx3 module
supports a female voice and a male voice
ctts engines are supported by it Windows
7 I5 NSS speech for Mac OS e-speak is
available on all other platform
so the next one is
import
OS
so the OS module in Python has function
for adding and deleting folders
retrieving their contents changing the
directory locating the current directory
and more before you can communicate with
the underlying operating system you must
import the OS module
the next one is
from
gtts
import
from
play sound
import
ant
so gdts python has a variety of apis
that can turn text into speech the
Google text to speech API often known as
gtts API is one of these apis gtts is a
simple to use program that turns enter
text into audio that can be saved as MP3
file
languages including English Hindi Tamil
French German Spanish and many more are
supported via gtts API
any one of the two accessible audio
speeds Rapid or slow may be used to
deliver the speech the voice of created
audio however cannot be changed as the
most recent version
so let me run this
so after importing major libraries let's
move forward and start creating user
interface
so I will write here import sorry
root equals to
t k
put dot
title
simply learn
to speech
converter
root Dot
geometry
I will give a thousand
plus 200 from y-axis and
and
80 from Top
okay
root dot resizable
will make it to like false
false
and again false
okay
then
dot configure
background should be PG equals to
use here hash
F7
AC
and
okay first I will explain this so here
TK stands for TK entered Library
every word in the string returned by the
title
method begins with an uppercase letter
like a title or a header the following
letter will be changed to uppercase if
the word contains a number or a symbol
one of the built-in methods in TK enter
is geometry which is used to specify
Dimension while TK enter widget windows
are mostly used to set the application
Windows Dimension length
the TK enter root Windows size can be
changed in accordance with the needs of
the user using the resizable this one
or we can forbid resizing of the TK
enter window in other words this
approach can be used to generate a
window with a defined size
Simple Text changes can be made to
labels using python TK enter config
function two widgets are shown in the
example below
a label and a button when the button is
pressed a function that is attached to
the button execute the label config
method
you can give background color as per
your choice I've gave this orange
something
so let's run this and see the first look
of UI by writing here I will write here
root
Dot main Loop
I will run and all
okay
so this is how our UI looks like first
UI so I can't resize because I gave here
false
I can't resize it
so if I will write here
set of false I will write here true
and again
through here
so then I will run again
[Music]
so now I can resize it
as per my choice
hey
yeah
so I will write here
false and again false
meant it
okay let's move forward and add some
logos in the application
I have already some PNG images on my
system you guys can use any picture of
your choice
I have some images here
images
so
you guys can use any picture of your
choice
so I will write here
simply
underscore logo
first two
photo
image
file
and path of file
e
zers
slash SLP
0 9 375
top
then
ETS folder
yes folder
then
simply dot PNG
okay then I will set label
put
H equals to
in play image
empty logo sorry
and background
I can copy from here
Dot
place
plus two
880 and y axis should be
like I will give here uh five
t
okay
let's run this root
dot in Loop
okay there is something error
search file directory
a there is one
now let me run this
yeah now you can see simply learn is
there I need
a little bit down
so let me write again
here
run it again
now it's looking good
yeah
the image object is written by the photo
image function output it's that easy to
display a picture in Python however the
photo image class only supports the GIF
and PNG images
which is a concern JPEG and gpg and PNG
are the formats that are most often used
the container box where the text or
images can be placed is specified by the
label the widget is used to inform the
user or other widgets that are utilized
in the python application
the text or a portion of the text shown
in the label can be configured using a
number of different parameters
the root window
is where all the widgets are placed
this one the root window is this all the
widgets are placed
even TK enter application must include
precisely one increase of the class TK
which is an instance of app is a
subclass of frame and app is in instance
of app
by positioning them in a precise
location with the parent Widget the port
manager organize visits the option used
by the geometry manager are anchor
border mode height width real width x
and y anchor shows the location where
the widget is anchored
okay let's move forward and add logo
here instead of this add One logo here
so I will make it comment down
it yeah
so for that I will write logo
underscore image
equals to
photo
image
then file
we'll copy the paths from here
sit here
okay so let me change it to speech
dot PNG perfect so root
dot icon photo
false
comma logo
underscore image
put dot Main
oops
let me run this
yeah now you can see a logo here
so the image object is written by the
photo image function
output it is the easy to display a
picture in Python however the photo
image class only supports the GIF and
PGM which is a concern JPEG gpg and PNG
are the formats that are most often used
the title bar icon of the TK enter top
level window is set using the icon photo
but in order to set any image as a title
bar icon it must be an object of the
photo image class
so OK logo is added
this logo is added now we will make one
upper frame like this one upper frame
till here something like here
and we will add the heading and logo in
the frame
okay so let me do this let me make it as
a command
okay so I will write here upper frame
was to frame
that root
and background should be
you can use any color
so I will write here hashtag one four
a
seven DD
cool
then width should be
yes I can give you 1200 is enough
and height should be
on 30 is fine
upper
m dot place
is equals to
zero and y equals to zero X and Y equals
to 0 y because we need at the top
so I will add one
picture there so picture
pursue
again photo
image
okay I can copy from
yeah same image I will add then label
and Venom but I'm adding here is like
upper
frame
image equals to
and background
should be the same
and Dot place
plus 2
and Y should be like I will give you a
20.
okay so let me run this
root dot main to
we'll run this run all
yeah
okay
okay here I have to write
y equals to 20.
and again
okay here what they should f is capital
hope now it will run properly
so the image is added here
yeah for the purpose of grouping and
arranging other widgets in a
user-friendly manner the frame widget is
a crucial it functions like a container
that organizes the positioning of other
widgets to arrange the layout and
provide these widgets the screen uses
rectangular regions
the root window is where all the widgets
are placed even TK enter application
must include precisely one instance of
the class TK
and the label is specifies the container
box where the text images can be placed
this widgets used to inform the user or
the other widgets that are utilized in
the python application
detects or a portion of the text shown
in the label can be configured using
several different parameters
okay so logo is added and it's looking
great
so
I hope you guys understand till here if
you have any question or any query
regarding
any sort of code
so just put as in comment our team will
shortly provide you the correct solution
I'm repeating again I hope you guys
understand till here if you have any
question or any query regarding any code
or if there are any question related to
python just put ads and comments our
team will shortly provide you the
correct solution
moving forward let's add a heading to
the application
so I will make it as a command
first I will add
[Music]
um
else below
better View
okay
so for that I will write here label
I have to head adding at the upper frame
so I will write here upper frame
should be
will give
X
each
converter
on should be
times
new
command
his side should be 40 is enough I guess
and it should be bold
come on
PG background color should be
I will add this one only so copy
paste it here
and foreground should be
White
and Dot place
at x equals to 250
and Y should be the same I guess I
should be
I will write 35
to 30.
let's run this root
dot main Loop
okay
than this
it's like option front
okay this is font I
want sorry my bad
oh it will work
I guess
yeah
so here you can see
text is added
so for the purpose of grouping and
arranging other widgets in use of
finding manner the frame widget is
crucial it function like a container
that organized positioning of the other
widgets
and the label is specified the container
box where the text or images can be
placed this widgets used to inform the
user of other widgets that are utilized
in the python application
and in TK enter there are three
different ways to specify a widget type
to put it simply use the string format
TK
direct phone format times 20 italic or
bold
font family size styles is the structure
of the string where the style can be any
legal mashup of text style keywords
okay so heading is added now let's move
forward and make our text box for
writings text to it
so let me make first as a comment
okay
so we are creating text box so I will
write here text box
equals to
text
and root window so I will write here
root
Bond
so let me tell you first I will create a
text box like this or this
so font
equals to
Library
20.
and background should be black or white
okay let's do black first
let it take it white only white
then relief is something
believe equals to
Groove
and wrap
keywords into
word or characters word
word
and border which should be
zero
okay
so text
box
dot place
should I place it x equals to
30.
comma y equals to
comma width
width
should be I will make it the longer ones
I will write here
then height
should be
so let's run this first root Dot
main Loop
let me run it
so yeah text box is created
hello guys
yeah
so text box is created so the python
application uses the text widgets to
display text Data the single line text
box is implemented using the entry
widgets which TK enter offers the
multi-line style text is with a variety
of styles and characteristics is shown
using the text widget
instead of group you can use raised flat
Ridge and many more it is used to make
contact within a text document with
using the wrap features in TK enter we
may enclose the characters or words in
the TK widgets you can use word cares or
none are the available default values
for the wrap properties
the TK enter button BD option determines
the width or stroke of the Border that
encircles the button the width of the
Border round a button can be changed
using the BD
so by positioning them in a precise
location with the parameter
the put manager organized widgets the
option used by this geometry manager are
anchor border mode height weight
X and Y and many more
so our text box is created
you can write anything
now let's move forward and add some
combo box for selecting voice and speed
so first I will but I will do it I will
make it command
here
I will write
gender box
for male female
or equals to
combo
box
put
value
if the question
email
and font should be
should be
your phone should be r
or b o
t e and 12 shell should be 12. then
there is something called state
ah
and then
with
12.
and
gender box
or place
so I will praise something here
something here like gender should be
here and speed should be here
so I will write here
equals to
40.
comma
y equals to
400.
and gender box
set
to mail
run it so root dot Main
to
let me run this
yeah so you can see male female yeah
this is combo box
so our combo box combines an entry field
and a list box one of the Tinker widgets
it has down arrow to choose from a menu
of possibilities it aids consumers in
choosing from the list of available
option
a pop-up of scrolling list box it
displayed down the entry field when the
user clicks on the drop down arrow on
the enter field
only when an option from the list box is
selected with the selected option be
shown in the entry field
if I will select errors then it will
show female of male
so some variables supported by TK enter
can be used to change the values of TK
inter widgets these variable operates as
a typical variable would
the values of these variable are set and
retrieved using the set and get methods
combobox combines a list box widgets and
an entry widget you can choose one value
from a group of values using a combobox
widget you can also input a custom value
in addition
so set text is used to set the text in
the entry box in the python TK enter it
serves the purpose of your entering text
into the entry box when used as a
function
we will write a function and use as a
button to invoke it
so okay so it's look great
moving forward let's add one more combo
box for the speed one like Fast medium
and slow
so whatever I will do I will copy first
I will make it as a comment
so
first I will copy this and I will paste
it here
and I will write
beatbox
again
hitbox
box
and I will set it to medium
him and that there will be three values
like
past
pm
and
slow
and I will press combo box
where should I place
will place it something like here I will
place it here
so
for that
I have to give X as
round 540
and Y should be same so
let me run this
and let's see so yeah
so it's looking fine function I use here
is same as the previous one that we did
for the gender one for this one
so I hope you guys understand till here
if you have any question or any query
regarding
any code any sort of code so just put us
in comments our team will shortly
provide you the current solution I'm
repeating again I hope you guys
understand till here if you have any
question or I can any query regarding
any code just put as in comments our
team will shortly provide you the
correct solution
so moving forward let's add play button
to playing the return tags but before
that let's add something called select
voice and select speed label for these
two combo works for like select select
voice type and select speed
so let's add them quickly so I will
write here label
I am adding it to the root window so I
will write here root
and text
equals to
select
voice type
and font
should be
times
woman
and size should be like 15 is enough I
guess it should be bold
comma
background color should be I will
here
copy
taste
yeah
foreground color should be
White
or place
equals to
and Y equals to
p 70.
okay let me copy this for the speed
up it and I will paste it here
I will write here speed
everything same
cut it and I will paste it here for the
running
so let me run this
select speed is there I don't know where
you select okay
okay I gave the same X values I guess
yeah
so here I have to write 540
let me run this again
yeah select voice mail female select
speed fast medium so
so the python application uses the text
widget to display the tax data the
single line textbook is implemented
using the entry widget which TK enter
offers
a foreground color of a button is set
using the TK enter button FG parameter
alternately the text color is on the
button
so it is looking cool now moving forward
let's add play button
somewhere here
so
I will write code for it
a
button
to I have one photo for it
Auto
let me copy the path
it here
and
headlight play
then play
scope vtn
first two
button
text
equal to X should be play
there is something called compound
to left
image
pursue
a button
comma
background should be
White
and width
is 130
font
equals to
Ariel
d
hold
on
border width
should be
2.1 e
c means centimeter
and there is something called command
equals to speak now
okay
let's go
etn Dot
place
X should be
why
should be
let me see root dot main to
come make it comment
okay okay
so this is a function
we haven't created function yet so I
will add it at the last
so till
see
this on a border with
okay okay w i d t h
I hope now it will work
okay TK enter
or in my bed
it's
yeah
so a python application can add buttons
by using the button widget these button
can show text or images that explain
what they are for when a button is
clicked
you can connect a function or method
that is called automatically using that
command
so here compound determined the best way
to display text and an image or the
label cursor
to find how the mouse will look when it
over the widget
so the TK enter button BD option control
the Border width or stroke surrounding
the button
and some TK enter widgets let you use
command binding to link a callback
function to an event
it enters that you may specify a
function name in the widgets command
option
so that it will be called whenever an
event occurs on the widget
okay so our UI for the text to speech
converter application is created and it
is looking fabulous
so now let's add function for converting
the text to speech sound
let me write the code first and then I
will explain you line wise okay
now we can write here
command equals to
signal
okay
so what I will do I will add a function
here
I will add function here
so let me write the code first then I
will explain you line-wise lies
so here I will write
ETS TTS is nothing just text to speech
variable
p y t t sx3
dot init
EF for function speak now
text equals to
text underscore box
dot get
1.0
LD and
gender equals to
Tender Box
a DOT get
and speed
equals to speed the score box
dot get
voices
equals to DTS dot get
property
prices
okay so there is one another function
set voice
if
gender
equals to equals to
male
ETS Dot
that property
it should be capital
property
[Music]
yeah
voice
voice ID versus ID should be zero
dot ID
s
dot say
whatever written on text
Dot
run
done and
I'm done for then else
PTS
dot that
property
boys
voices
dot ID
s dot say
text
and again TTS Dot
done
and
oh
here's I will for
I will write code for that speed if
text
and again if
speed plus 2 equals to
passed
and
ETS dot set
property
and rate
should be
add to voice
or else if
feed
also equals to
yum
so then
ETS dot set
property
and rate should be
150.
that voice function will be called
else
ETS thoughts that
property
ets.set property and rate should be
age should be
60.
at voice
okay so function is created dot get dot
get get property fine text okay
now let me run this
so let me explain you
EDS is nothing just a variable
to text to speech and init pytis X3
engine has started obtains a pointer to
an instance of an engine that will
utilize the specified driver if another
engine instance is already using the
given driver the other engine instance
is returned if not a new engine is built
so speak now is a function which using
get function I am getting the values of
the text box voice I will show you it
so
from this
from this speak now I am getting the
value of text male and female then speed
and using the get property I am getting
the voices of male and female
in set voice what I did using ID 0 for
mail and assetting into the mail and
using id1 for female and assigning it to
the female
and in this LC slider I am setting speed
to a particular values using the rate
function and assigning them speed in
frames per second
so now let's see text to speech
converters is working or not
so what I will write here hello
coders
welcome
to
simply learn
so I will play
hello coders welcome to simplerlearn
hope you hear the sound
I repeat hope you heard the sound
and same thing I will from from female
okay object run and wait
okay there is an error
done and wait
I will write
let me run this again
hello simply learn
hello simple learn
and again with female voice
I will write here hello simply learners
subscribe
to our
YouTube
Channel
hello simple Learners subscribe to our
YouTube channel
then I will play it too fast
hello simple Learners subscribe to our
YouTube channel
and I will put slow
hello simple learners
subscribe to our YouTube channel
[Music]
what is a specific cognition system
a program capacity to convert spoken
language into written language is known
as a speech recognition system also
known as automatic seize recognition
computer voice recognition or speech to
text despite being sometimes confused
with voice recognition speech
recognition focus on converting speech
form a verbal to a text format whereas
voice recognition only aims to
distinguish the voice of a certain
person
voice and speech recognition are two
distance Technologies and they shouldn't
be confused
to recognize word in spoken language
speech recognition is used voice
recognition uses biometrical
Technologies to recognize a specific
person by their voice
so after knowing what is this speech
recognition system let's move forward
and see how does speech recognition
system work
PC cognition in Python works with
algorithm that perform linguistic and
acoustic modeling acoustic modeling is
used to recognize phonetics in our
speech to get the more significant part
of speech as words and sentences speech
recognition start by taking the sound
energy produced by the person speaking
and converting it into the electrical
energy
with the help of microphone it then
converts the electrical energy from
analog to digital and finally to the
text
it breaks the audio data down into
sounds and it analyzes the sound using
algorithm to find the most probable word
that fits that audio
all of this is done using natural
language processing NLP and neural
networks
hidden Markov models can be used to find
temporal patterns in speech and improve
accuracy so here is one question for you
guys I will give you one minute for this
you can comment or you can give your
answer in the chat section so I can see
if the answer is given by you are right
or wrong
I am repeating again so here is one
question for you guys I will give you
exactly one minute for this you can
comment or you can give answer in the
chat section so I can see if the answer
is given by you are right or wrong
so the question is
which of the following is the correct
extension for the python file
I'm repeating again which of the
following is the correct extension of
the Python file
option a DOT python option b dot PL
option C Dot py and option D dot p
so let us know your answer in these
comment section below
so I'm starting a timer of one minute
just type your answer in the comment
section or in the chat section do let me
know your answers please I kindly ask
that everyone take part in this to make
this live session exciting
so I am starting the timer
you can comment or you can give your
answer in the chat section so I can see
if the answers given by you are right or
wrong so the question is which of the
following is the correct extension of
the Python file
37 seconds remaining
option a DOT python option b dot PL
option C dot py option D dot p
let us know your answer in the comment
section below
I can't ask that everyone take part in
this to make the live session exciting
you have 15 seconds remaining
10 seconds more
which of the following is the correct
extension of the Python file
three two one after that allotted time
has passed Those Who provided the
correct or response will receive as
response and those Who provided the
incurrent response will receive one
okay so now let's move to our
programming part to create a speech
recognition system using python so first
we will open a command prompt to write a
command to open jupyter notebook so here
we will write Jupiter
notebook
press enter
so this is the landing page of Jupiter
notebook and here you can select new
python file
so this is how the Jupiter notebook UI
looks like so at first we will import
some major libraries of python which
will help us in creating speech
recognition system
so here we will write
first let me remain rename this
speech peacock
teach
underscore
recognition
and second import
S three
press enter
so the incredibly attention repeat the
incredibly extensible speech recognition
Library serves as a wrapper for a number
of well-known speech apis the speech
recognition Library includes default API
key for one of these the Google web
speech API hard coded that implies that
you can start moving without needing to
register for a service
and python project would benefit greatly
from using the speech recognition
package due to its versatility and
usability
and then pytts X3 a python text to
speech conversion library is called pyts
X3
it is compatible with python 2 and
Python 3 and work offline unlike
competing libraries to obtain a
reference to a pyts X3 engine instance
an application calls the pytts X3 init
it is very user friendly program that
turns type text to into speech
so moving forward let's write code for
actual speech recognition system
so here I will write
Sr equals to speech
underscore
recognition
Dot
recognizer
R must be Capital here
I will write with
speech
underscore
recognition
Dot microphone
s
ource
two
then colon
yeah
here
I will write print
right here okay silence
is
then I will write here Sr dot adjust
underscore for underscore
ambient
underscore noise
then source 2 comma duration
equals to 2.
okay
then enter
then I will print something like
Peak
now
please
something like that
then I will write here audio
to
equals to Sr
Dot listen
source
2.
and here I will write for text equals to
Sr
Dot
recognize
okay
underscore
Google
audio
2.
and here I have to print in small
letters
in lower case so I will write here text
equals to text
dot lower
yeah just
then here I will write print
it you say
Plus
text
everything look great
so I recognize there is a machine
ability to listen to spoken words and
identify them
you can then use a speech recognition in
Python to convert the spoken words into
text make a query or a give a reply you
can even program some devices to respond
to these spoken words
like every time they recognize speech
from mic function is invoked the
recognizer is calibrated for changing
noise condition using the edges for
ambient noise this one for ambient noise
the backlog parameter of the listen
function allow a quiz size to be
specified it will listen to what we are
speaking or saying
this recognize Google
a function on the recognizer class
which you have now developed will be
used to query the Google value speech
API and convert spoken words into text
recognize Google needs the argument
audio data in order to function properly
otherwise it will fail
python built-in function lower is mostly
used to handle strings
the lower method converts each Capital
character in The provided string to
lowercase before returning the lower
caste string hit accept no arguments it
returned to the original text if the
supplied string has no capital letters
now let's check whether it's working or
not so I will run it yeah
run all
hello how are you doing
you can see hello how are you doing
printed
so let me try another one
subscribe to Simply learn YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply learn
so here you can see subscribe to Simply
on YouTube channel and press that Bell
icon to never miss any update from
Simply learn is printed
so a speech to text is working fine
so I hope you guys understand till here
if you have any questions or any queries
regarding any code or you have any
questions just put us in comments our
team will shortly provide you with the
correct solution
now moving forward what if you want that
system we'll write what we are saying
and speak that too
this will be printed and now moving
forward what if you want the system will
write what we are saying and speak that
too
so for that we will write a small line
of code
so first we will do
we will create one here
like we will insert cell below we will
write a function here so t f
speak now
command
colon then voice equals to
p y t t sx3
dot init
okay
then voice dot say
command
and voice
dot run
and
width
yeah
so what we will do here
we will write like speak
now
then
so his voice is nothing just a variable
to text to speech and init pytx3 engine
has started obtains a pointer to an
instance of an engine that will utilize
the specified driver
if another engine stand is already using
the given driver the other engine stance
is written if not a new engine is built
a speed now is a function in which using
get function I am getting the values of
the text this one I will get
now let's run this sort of code and
let's see if it is working or not so I
will run
hello how are you all
Peak now is not different okay
speak now okay and is small
okay my bad ranges again
hello how are you all
I hope you can hear properly so let me
run this again for another demo example
subscribe to Simply learn YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply learn
subscribe to simple and YouTube channel
and press the Bell icon to never miss
any updates from simplerlearn yeah so I
hope you guys understand Taylor if you
have any question or any queries
regarding any code
or you have any question related to
python just put as in comments our team
will shortly provide you with the
correct solution
okay okay moving forward so at last
let's create a speech recognition system
from which we can open our websites and
all like YouTube like Facebook like
simply learn anything so we will open
open new file for this I will create the
separate one
here I will write speech to web
websites
okay
speech
to web
so here I will import import speech
underscore
recognition
and
import
pyts X3
then one major Library import
web browser
okay then I will run it yeah
I hope you already know these two first
two libraries so this is third library
is used for
web browser is the file source code the
web browser modules offers a high level
user interface that enables user to view
web-based content
in most cases executing the open
function from the this module will
result in the desired outcome
so moving forward let me write code for
it
so I will write code first then I will
explain you line wise
so I will write
if
underscore underscore
name
then again to underscore equals to
equals to
underscore main then again underscore
then colon
yeah then you have to give a path like
for your browser you can use Edge you
can use Google Chrome anything Firefox
anything
so here I will give path path equals to
then
C drive I have my path
already
program
files
and
x 86
Microsoft
Edge
then
okay then
application
then msh
dot e x e
you have to write at the end this
percentage s
don't forget to write this
okay so path is set so let me create Sr
equals to
speech
recognition
Dot recognizer
same as previous one
and I will write with
speech underscore
recognition
Dot microphone
as source
and Sr dot adjust
or
ambient
noise
then source
now everything seems good
let me write print
but we have wrote there like speak
now please so here I will write
please
say something
to open
okay
I'll write audio
equals to
Sr Dot listen
that source
and I will print
like what you said
so it will here hearing
and I will here I try and accept
then try
so here I will write destination
equals to Sr
dot recognize
underscore Google
then audio
end
you asked
to open
right here Plus
destination
okay
so then web
browser
browser dot get
that path
then open
that destination
destination
okay
so here I will write that accept
caption
caption as
you can write e
then print
if there will be error
error
stria
e
okay
so I recognize the machine ability to
listen to spoken words and identify them
you can use speech recognition in Python
to convert the spoken word into text you
can even program some devices to respond
to these spoken words every time the
recognized speech from mic function is
invoked the recognizer is calibrated for
changing noise condition using the
adjust ambient noise method
a socket is all ready to receive
connection after calling the listen
function prior to performing the accept
method on the server socket the listen
method should be called the backlog
parameter of the listen function allow a
queue size to be specified it will
listen to what we are speaking or saying
the recognize Google function on the
recognizer class which you have now
developed will be used to query the
Google web speech API and will convert
spoken words into text
recognize Google needs the argument
audio data in order to function properly
otherwise it will fail
okay
so okay so let's try this it's working
or not
let me run this
okay invalid syntax perhaps you forgot a
comma
okay let me see
that print
error
Inc it should be yeah
okay let me check this
foreign
let me run this again
valid syntax perhaps you forgot a comma
okay
try to run this again
two
okay
let me remove this
I guess it will work fine
still
didn't put okay okay no issues
so here I will write
again
except
exception
e
and
errors
TR okay I forgot to write plus okay okay
e
yeah now it will work fine
www.youtube.com
so here you can see YouTube is open
yeah
so we will try this one more time
www.facebook.com
so here you can see Facebook is open
one more last time
www.simplyland.com
you can check our amazing courses on
different different Technologies here on
simply land website simplylean.com
data analysis is a process for acquiring
arranging and changing data so that
prediction about the future and the data
driven decision can be made
finding potential answer to business
problem is also helpful
let's move forward and see steps to
perform data analysis
so first one is Define the question what
commercial issue are you attempting to
resolve by raising it as a query you can
concentrate on coming up with a precise
response
and the second one is collecting data to
answer specified research question test
hypothesis and evaluate outcomes data
collection is the act of acquiring and
measuring information on variables of
interest in a systematic and defined
manner and the third one is cleaning
data
your data should be explored cleaned up
and deducted and organized as
unnecessary to whatever needs to be done
but wait a moment give it some time
and the fourth one is analyzing data
perform a variety of analysis to gain
insights concentrate on a descriptive
diagnostic predictive and prescriptive
types of data analysis and the fifth one
is visualization and sharing your
findings how can you most effectively
impart your knowledge and suggestions
the trick is using communication and
visualization Technologies together
after seeing the steps to perform data
analysis let's move forward and see some
importance of data analysis so python is
a high level open source interpreted
language that offers a fantastic
approach to object oriented programming
it is the warning skills might quickly
learn how to utilize it furthermore it
works better for rapid prototyping there
are some most common libraries used for
data analysis the first one is numpy
pandas
matplotlib sci-fi
seabon
and many more
so
so what do you guys think about data
analysis do share your thoughts with us
in the chat section
now let's move to our programming part
to perform data analysis using python so
first we will open command prompt to
write command to open Jupiter notebook
so we will write Jupiter
notebook
press enter
so this is the landing page of Jupiter
notebook and select open
new python file
so this is how the UI looks like so at
first we will import some major
libraries of python which will help us
in mathematical functioning so the first
one is numpy numpy is a python Library
used for working with arrays it also has
a functions for working in the domain of
linear algebra and matrices it is an
open source projected and you can use it
freely numpy stand for numerical python
so we will write
import
come by
as NB
so here NP is denoting number
so we will import the next libraries
pandas pandas is a software Library
written for the Python programming
language for data manipulation and
Analysis in particular it offers data
structures and operations for
manipulating numerical tables and time
series so we will write
import
and as
as PD
here PD is for denoting pandas so we
will
close back
so after importing the libraries we will
move ahead and import data set so for
importing data set we have to write data
equals to PD dot read
underscore CSV
and here we have to write our data set
name
data set
insta dot CSV
press shift plus enter yeah here PD is
for pandas Library read is used for
reading the data set
from the machine and CSV is used for the
type of file which you want to read so
then we can write data to see our data
so
see this is how our data set look like
so let's first rename this column name
followers
this one followers in Million by writing
followers only because it is so lengthy
and this followers column we are going
to use most of time so it will save our
time
so we will write here data
dot rename
column
equals to that Curly braces
here we will write the name of column
which you want to followers
colon
to followers
so here we will write in place
equals to true
okay then here we will write data
okay it's not changed yet
okay okay because it is follow words
to give one space here
yeah done so rename function is a
function which is used to rename the
column name so there are many keywords
arguments like index column access copy
in place level errors which you can use
as a parameter so column name is changed
to followers let's move on so here you
can see the three dots this one
and we are unable to see our full data
like only we can see the 10 rows so like
we have thousand rows right so for that
we can write
here we can write PD dot set
underscore options
display
dot Max
underscore columns
and here we can write
none
after that this is for columns and we
can write for the same for the rows
sort underscore options
it is option not options
okay we can write here display
dot Max
underscore for rows
perfectly done okay we can write here
none
yep so pandas features and options this
one
system that allows you to modify various
aspects of their behavior users are most
likely to change display related options
so the maximum number of rows by default
is done you can see one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten so the
maximum number of rows by default is
done all rows of data frame are
considered if the value is set to none
set the display value by setting it into
zero
yeah
so moving ahead here you can see the NN
values like this n a n and Below n a n n
so NN means not a number and it is one
of the typical method for representing
the data set missing values it is a
unique floating point value and can only
be changed to the float type so let's
change it to 0 for the better result and
the better prediction so we will write
here data dot will
any
zero
so by writing this we will shift plus
enter
so all n a values are now changed to
zero with the help of this fill any
function this fill in a method replaces
the null values with a specified value
so after this let's move on to the
another function which is shape
so we will write data dot shape
then shift plus enter yeah so this shape
function will return you a number of
rows and columns your data set have
so here we have thousand rows you can
see
and seven columns
yeah so let's move on to the another
amazing function which is info so here
we will write data dot info
effect so data frames information is
printed by the info method the data
includes the total number of columns
their labels data guides memory use
range index and another number of cells
in column note that the information
method does indeed print the information
so here you can see all information has
been printed like all the columns name
all the non-null values count and data
types
for the particular column so let's move
forward and see our next function which
is data dot columns so which is data dot
columns
okay again I wrote wrong
okay perfect so as per the name you can
easily tell me in the chat section what
is going to print for us so
this function is going to print all the
columns name so here we have names like
name rank category followers audience
country authening engagement engagement
average data type is object why data
type is object data type is object
because this is taking as the one
category that is why it is taking as an
object so let's move forward for the
next function which is described so data
frame comprises of numerical data and
each column's description includes it
following details like count is the
total amount of non empty values mean
the standard deviation and many others
so here we will write data dot describe
Open brackets
so
C
so here you can see all the columns
which have numerical data is displayed
by the full description
so this is our mean
count STD minimum 25 percent of the
particular date column 50 and 70 percent
and the maximum value
present in the column so moving forward
let's solve some questions like how to
show audience country like from which
country we have the most number of
followers so let me write this question
as a comment so for comment we have to
use hashtag so here you can write how to
show
audience
from
pitch
country we have
most
number of followers
okay perfect yeah so so let's solve this
with a small line of code we can write
here data
here column name as audience
entry
dot value
underscore
counts
normalize
was to true
then we will round it it to
two
okay here we have to write the capital T
perfect
yeah
so returns an object with counts of
distinct value the resulting object will
be arranged in descending order with the
first element being the one of the that
appears most frequently by default
exclude any values index value count
normalize equals to false sort equals to
True ascending equals to false or bins
equals to none is a syntax of counting
values the normalized function in Python
processing package is used to normalize
the data it accepts an area as input and
converts its content to a range between
0 and 1. after that it will give a back
an output array with the same size of
input array if we remove round function
it will show the output like it is still
showing the values but we round this
value for how many decimal places we
have to see the value that is why I has
written 2 here for two decimal places so
we will write
here
yeah the data look like good
so from this question we can say
maximum audience is from United States
with like 28 percent followed by India
like 16 percent and Brazil 15 and so on
so
let's move to the our next question
which is how to show audience country
like who is having more followers from
India or a particular country
so let me write it as a comment so
how to
audience
okay this is three hashtag
so
audience
country
like who is
having
more
followers
the question is that like who which
influencer is having more followers from
India
so
don't worry we will like do for the more
and more countries so
here I have to write data underscore
IND for India so equals to data
and again data this is our data frame
name so
audience
see
here we can write double squares to
yeah
we can write data
so here we are giving data IND name of
you can say a variable name and data is
our data frame name and audience country
is column name and India is a country
name from which we want to collect
influencer so let me do this
let me debug the error audience country
Okay C is capital here
yeah perfect
so
these all influencers are who has
audience from India so like Cristiano or
Virat Kohli that khabi Justin Bieber
Instagrams in the rock
and so on
so so let's take another country this
time we will take United States
so we will write here data underscore
USA
okay data
data again
and
audience
sees Capital now country
perfect
question equals to
it is USA or United States
in the United States perfect
so United
States
so data
dot USA
this time I'm using
uh
score and Dot head
so we have to write same code like we
did for India here I have used the head
function
you can see the add function
to show only five first rows
you can also write only data USA so to
see the full data
so I will write like this I can do like
this so here I can see the full data
The influencer Who belongs to United
States that audience country belongs to
United States so
I will control that or head function
yeah
so okay let's do for One More Country
browse it so let's write data
it uh uh underscore Brazil
data
again data
accordions
is capital country equals equals to
oh Brazil how this return
[Music]
is Brazil
okay Brazil P capital
so here we will write Brazil
e is capital forgot
so here we will write data underscore
Brazil
so we have to write same code like we
did for India and USA so here let me use
a function called tail
so
here I have used the tail function to
show only last five rows head will show
you the first five rows and the tail
will show you the last five rows so you
can also write only Brazil to see full
data so let's move forward and see our
next question which is
like how to show audience for a
particular category
so let me write this question as a
command for your better understanding
and readability
so here we will write
how
to show
audience
for a particular
category
okay
so this time I will use fashion category
so let's write code for this one so
fashion
equals to data underscore USA
data underscore USA
right here category
okay dot Str
Dot
contains
to write your fashion
comma any
equals to false
okay fashion
bats
yeah here I am using the data USA set
for retrieving the fashion category we
can do this for all the data using our
data frame name we can also write data
only here so I have given the column
names as a category and Str contains
means string which contains fashion this
is what we have to print and any should
not be false
okay so let's see
if white is showing this uh data
underscore user
okay here f is capital
it's capital
so
yeah
okay
see these all influencers which have
audience from United States like Kendall
Jenner zandia and Beyonce
so these all influencers which have
audience from United States and belong
to some kind of fashion industry
so moving ahead let's take one more
category this time we will take a sports
category because Sports is something
like which most of people like so we
will write here Sports
this time we will take India data set
IND I guess we have wrote the same yeah
so here we will write data
underscore
ie
and
category
same Str dot contains
of it
we will write here
we check one thing
so Sports as his capital
port
comma any
equals to
false
then Sports again
okay this time we will use Sports dot
hat
so this time I use India data and all
the things are same just replace fashion
with the sports
so
see these are all the influencer
Cristiano Virat Kohli
Sharma hardik pandya which have audience
from India and belong to some kind of
sports industry so as I'm talking before
like we can use data frame name for all
data instead of using
like India data or
like this one so we can also write like
this data only
okay let me
create one more
for the
or only data so we can write like here
Sports
so
data
here we can
it here we are like taking our data like
full data frame name so we can write
category
category name
so
dot Str dot contains
contains
ports
comma n a equals to false
okay here we will write export
okay
so as I'm talking before like we can use
data frame name so instead of like
writing only data and your data USA
browser so this influencers like from
Sports category belong to any one
country so this is our full
influencer category so let's move
forward and
do this again for the music category
like because music is also one of the
favorite category of you folks
so we were to write music
okay music
question
we will do is for the whole data so data
data
category
yeah Dot
contains
I guess m is capital in music
yep
it's Capital so music
n equals to
so this data will contain all the
category influencer name which belongs
to music category whether they are from
India USA Brazil or any other country
doesn't matter
see you can see Indonesia South Korean
so moving forward let's change our some
column data types to integer type
so we can write here data
equals to
data dot as type
count bracket then curly braces so here
we can write
followers
if followers followers
foreign
and take it from here authentic
engagement
overcome the spelling mistakes so I can
check from here
integer
uh
that's two four one more engagement
average
so integers
so here we can write data dot hat
yeah perfect
all the columns changed to in scissor
type now so this is how we can change
like data type in column here like data
is our data frame name
this one and the as type this one as
type
is the method like which gives a back a
new data frame with the requested data
type
for the data to select a data type for
each column you can either cast the
entire data frame so that the type or I
use Python dictionary like in the
following example like categories pearls
or whatever respectively
I repeat calories per decision are all
in like integers value respectively so
let's move to our next question which is
like top 20 character grief by follower
before making graph for this one let me
create like top variable followers
so
here I can write like 20 top
followers
is two
data
Dot and largest
and largest
like we need 20 so we can write here
I am writing followers spelling like
this because we have to look like this
followers f-o-l-l-wers
so
of it yeah so top 20 followers we have
taken as a variable name to store
followers and to obtain the first and
rows arranged by the column in
descending order use of the enlarges
function which is this one and largest
function
in specified columns are also written uh
I repeat but they are not used to
determining ranking so data frame dot
enlarges you can write this syntax like
this self comma like n comma column
names or keep you can also write keep
equals to first so top 20 followers are
generated let me create graph so
first we will import Library like one of
the main library for visualization which
is matplotlib so for importing this we
have to write import
cave so
we can also write
like
instead of writing import we can also
write from
matplotlip
both
port
By plot
as
LT
so for the Python programming language
and it's some bi-numerical mathematics
matplotlib is a graphing library with
the help of general purposes like GUI
toolkits like Tinker python QT and gtk
it offers an object oriented API for
embedding plots into applications
so after this let's create
the figure so we have to write PLT Dot
figure
that again figure size
equals to
we can take 12 and 8
perfect
so we will get figure 2 here
equals to PLT dot bar
top 20
but we have to take followers
dot category
comma category
top
followers
okay followers
but
followers
comma like label should be
should be followers
it should be
like I'm taking 0.8 here
and my favorite color is maroon
so I will take
maroon color
so
PLT
dot X sticks
font size
should be like 12 and rotation
should be 90
perfect
so let's create Y and X labels so PLT
dot y label
followers
from a font size
should be let me take 16 here
LT dot X label
category
and font size should be font size
should be 16.
so let's set the title for this now for
plt.ti
title
is
oh
categories
the words
comma
font size
should be let's
take it as 20
and PLT Dot
underscore layout
layout
listen and we can write PLT Dot
tick
label
underscore format
is equals to
y
why
style should be plain
okay
so this is how the visualization look
like here I have used the bar graph for
this visualization and top 20 followers
dot category and this one top 20
followers dot followers are the X and Y
values and color is something like which
color you want to show with and you can
choose as your preference and X and Y
labels are used to print in X and Y
coordinate like this followers in
millions and category so this tight
layout this one this type layout
and
I repeat
this tight layout function this one
and this type layout function this one
this title out function in pipelot
module of matte plotly libraries used to
automatically adjust subplot parameters
to give a specified padding so plt.tick
label format is used for in which Axis
or in which style you want to print
plt.tick label is not necessary to write
or to showing paragraph So
like when we can remove this so our
visualization should look like this so
it is not necessary
okay
tools that
so let's move to our next question like
using bar graphs
let's see how our category look likes so
first we will create
I'm writing here
showing
categories
using
pie chart
okay
so using
using pie chart let's see how our
category look likes first we will create
categories so we have to write here
like types
equals to data Dot
category
Dot
value
underscore counts
and this one yeah types
okay
types
dot reset
underscore index
yeah here we have used types as a
variable and value counts uh like we
already discussed before
so these all are the categories
from our data
so let's create the pie chart now so for
plotting a pie chart we have to write
PLT dot pi
like types dot values
values comma label
should be
types dot Index this one label should be
type dot Index this music Cinema
lifestyle modeling and so on so index
comma
label distance
to 1.2
and then Auto
PCD should be
like
some days 1.2
f
percentage so like
shadow
should be true
perfect and let me add one more thing
start
angle
okay
should be 60.
okay so PLT Dot
title
that is like
you can say different
categories
comma font size
should be 20
and that's PLT Dot
plot
so let me check everything is correct
values labels okay here we can write
labels
type dot values labels equals to type
dot index and label distance equals to
1.2
so here Auto PCT is equals to
like okay Shadow equals to True perfect
and starting is equals 20 60 so PLT or
title categories okay okay fine
everything is great
so
it's not coming okay perfect so this is
how our pie chart look like this is
looking like a mess because we have more
than 100 categories that is why like 100
percent is splitting into 152 categories
like you can see here
we have 152 categories
Okay so
this is how
sorry this is how our like pie charts
look like for our different categories
let me try D capital
yeah perfect
so Microsoft developed Microsoft Excel I
spreadsheet for Windows Mac OS Android
and iOS it has calculating or Computing
capabilities graphing tools pivot table
and the Visual Basic for applications
the Microsoft Office program package
includes Excel users of Microsoft Excel
May format arrange and compute data in a
spreadsheet data analysts and other
analysts can make information easier to
examine as data is added or altered by
organizing data using tools like Excel
the boxes and excels are referred to as
cell and they are arranged in a row and
column the key features of excels are
they spreadsheet document in Ms Excel
can have headers and Footers and user
can protect their data by giving it
password protection
and the second one is filtering is
supported allowing you to locate the
necessary data in your spreadsheet and
replace it with the appropriate value
after discussing what is Excel let's go
through and see what is python so python
is the one of the most popular
programming language available today it
is widely used in various sector of
business such as programming web
development machine learning and data
science given its spreadsheet use it is
not surprising that python has surpassed
Java as a top programming language
python frequently used to create
software website and to perform data
analysis and many more because python is
a journal purple language it may use to
develop a wide range of programs and
isn't alert for any particular issues
so the key features of python are it is
open source and free
python can be downloaded from the
company official website it is simple to
download and install
pythony's open source because allowing
users with solid technical background to
modify the code to suit certain business
use case and product requirements since
python is a language for beginners most
anyone with the understanding of
programming can quick pick it up and
begin coding
so after seeing what is python let's
move forward and see what is automating
Excel with python
we all know python is dominant
everywhere and we also know that
compared to other language python is
beginner friendly and simpler to use
automation is the one of the coolest
thing you can do with python so how to
automate an Excel sheet in Python
imagine that you are asked to create
accounts for 30 000 employees on a
website what would you think you will
undoubtedly become frustrated carrying
out this talks manually and repeatedly
additionally it will take too much time
which is not the wise choice
so just try to picture that what it is
like for employees who work in data
entry
the responsibility is to extract the
data from tables like Excel or Google
sheet and insert it in the another
location they read various magazines and
website get the data there and they are
entered it into the database
additionally they must perform the
calculation for the entries in general
this job performance determines how much
money is made greater entry volume more
pay of course everyone wants a higher
salary in their job so however don't you
find doing the same things over and over
boring
the question is now
how can I accomplish it quickly
and how to automate my work spend an r
in coding and automating these kind of
course to make your life simpler rather
than performing these kinds of things by
hand by just writing fewer lines of
python code you can automate your
laborious activity in simpler so overall
python Excel automation is a creative
method that allows you to build visual
reports on python in a smoother manner
similar to how you would on Excel
businesses can use Python Excel
automation to streamline their operation
in accordance with their requirements
so here is one question for you guys I
will give you one minute for this you
can comment or you can give answer in
chat section so I can see the answers
are given by you are correct or not
I'm repeating again here is one question
for you guys I will give you one minute
for this you can comment or you can give
your answer in chat section so I can see
if the answers given by you are right or
wrong
so the question is which type of
programming does python support
object oriented programming structured
programming functional programming and
all of the mentioned
so I am repeating again which type of
programming does python support
option a object oriented programming
option b structured programming
functional programming and all of the
mention
so I am starting the timer of one minute
just type your answers in comment
section or in chat section do let me
know your answers guys so like please I
want that everyone should participate in
this so I am starting the timer
so
so your time starts now
so I want that everyone should
participate in this guys please to let
me know your answer in chat section or
in comment section
so I can see if the answers given by you
are right or wrong so
like 36 seconds or more
is guys I want that everyone should
participate in this so
let me know your answers in chat section
or comment section
so you can just type the answers or a b
c d
your wish totally your wish so
10 seconds are left guys hurry up please
I want that everyone should participate
in this five second more
okay the time is over we will give reply
those who gave correct answers and those
who didn't give correct answer we will
give you a reply with the correct answer
okay so no worries
so now let's move to our programming
part to perform Excel automation using
python so first we will open command
prompt to write command to open Jupiter
notebook filter
notebook
yeah
so this is the landing page of Jupiter
notebook and select open
select here new open new file
so this is how the Jupiter notebook UI
looks like so at first we will import
some major libraries of python which
will help us in importing our workbook
or worksheet so the first one is let me
first rename this
we will write Auto meeting
so
using python
yeah sounds good
okay
so the first one is Open PI Excel open
py
Excel okay I have to write import yeah
perfect
so a python package called open pyxl can
read and write Excel 2010 xlx format
Excel SM format xltx and xltm files
it was created since there was no
library that could read and write office
open XML files natively from python
since open py Excel was initially based
on PHP Excel all pressed to the PHP
Excel team so open py Excel does not by
default provide protection from your
quadratic blow up or billion after XML
as sold install diffused XML to protect
yourself from these assaults so
we will write open py Excel and then
like
yeah
so
then we will write for important our
workbook so we can write here from open
p y Excel
report
workbook
code
underscore workbook
is capital here
so and this is for code for the
importing our workbook so let me write
in command like you can import workbook
like this so I can write you can import
workbook
this
okay perfect
yeah
so
let me import workbook so I have to
write WP for Workbook question
load
underscore workbook
the destination of the workbook so uh
the destination is in like desktop so I
have to write C
users
LP
zero nine
three seven five
stop
yeah Dash automation
that
we learn
Dot
cell SX format
okay cool
users SLP this one desktop automation
simply learn DOT xlx fine
so our workbook is loaded to Jupiter
notebook
we can see yeah perfect no error so
let's activate this workbook for the use
so we have to write WS for worksheet so
worksheet equals to WB DOT active
active
like import from openmpi Excel our book
there must be all it is accessible
through the workbook dot property active
so that's why we have write WB DOT
active so after making workbook active
so we will print our workbook like
we can print
so print
WS
so here
so here you can see the sheet one so it
is showing worksheet sheet1 why sheet1
because if you open your workbook and
see here is your worksheet name like
like so this is my automation
file
this is simply learn
so here you can see
the sheet1
that is why it is showing sheet1 there
so uh okay so let me just
finish it
so moving forward
let's change the worksheet name so
I will write here import
open
pyxl
so like it's your wish that you want to
write this import file or like this
thing this is not necessary at all so
now I will import the workbook so I will
write here
WB equals to open py Excel
dot load underscore
workbook
when pyx L it is
my bad sorry guys
so
you have to give the path so I can copy
path from here
yeah perfect
okay sounds good
yeah yeah WB underscore sheet
equals to
WB and square brackets then you have to
write the sheet name so there we have
sheet 1.
so sheet1 okay correct
so I can change with WB underscore sheet
dot title
sheet
equals to
code with
simply learn
perfect
yeah seems good let me save this
WD dot save
and the same
copy
here paste
yeah
so when a sheet is generated it
immediately receives a name like they
have sequential numbers of names like
sheet sheet1 sheet 2 and so on with the
worksheet you can modify this name
whenever you want to like using the
title property so
here let me save this
and yeah where are so again go to Simply
learn
yeah you can see code base simply learn
first it was sheet1 and now it is
changed to codebase Simply learn
so let me cut this again
okay
so if you want to change the color of
your sheet name tab whereas written code
will simply learn so you can write like
here
you can write
WD
or okay let me make this new one
okay right I will write here so
underscore sheet
dot sheet
underscore properties
app
color
was to
here you have to give hex
values so four zeros okay
so let me save this okay it is saying
sheet1 why sheet1 because we already
changed sheet1 to code which simply
learn so what we have to do is
here we have to write code with
simply learn
pre-learn
okay same same simply learn simply learn
same code code yeah so what I will do
here I will just
make W Capital so yeah
now it will work fine yeah
so
if you save or run your code like like
this let me
let me show you one thing uh like
color is already changed wait for one
minute guys I will show you something
crazy so it will see like this w
okay
so here I will small
so
if you save or run your code not
actually save but run your code while
your Excel sheet is open so my Excel
sheet is open code will simply learn
yeah
so my Excel sheet is open so it will
give you error like where
repeat like what error
this okay let me do one thing this is
one okay
it will give you
simply Land one does not exist let me
check this is simply learn code with
simply learn
one
code with okw's capital there
okay see this is a
permission denied
then the location it is showing
so this is something important to
remember that Excel file should be
closed while running the code and
repeating again so like this is
something important to remember that
Excel file should be closed while
running the code
so first what I have to do is close the
Excel file
then I have to run it again so no error
now so here you can see
what we simply learn that red color came
yeah perfect
so moving forward let's create new
workbook till we were working on the
same worksheet which was present me in
my like desktop so let's create new book
so for that I have to write
import
cell as X writer
so I will write here in command to
create
new notebook
xlsx
writer
Dot
workbook
and where you want to
save the workbook so I will give
the same
art
but with different name
so this time I will give only like
coders simply
okay simply coders
then I will write WD class close
okay I will run it yeah
so the primary class export by the XLS
writer module in the workbook class and
that is only class you will need to
instantiate directly so the workbook
class represents both the whole
spreadsheet as it appears in the Excel
and the Excel file as it is stored on
the disk internally
so you can see now
yeah you can see now
the workbook which is created in the
desktop with the same name is like
simply coders
so this is done
let's move forward and let's retrieve
cell values so right now we are not
having any data inside the workbook so
let's put some random values like names
and all so uh
I will put some random values
we'll put here
names
okay
mayank
kaushal
okay
well
like jelly
Chloe
so let's save it
let's save it
and let's move to our coding part so
here what I have to write to retrieve
cells here I just write a equals to A is
variable here so I am assigning this WS
that
A1 value
the value which is presented at A1
so here I will write in comments
like
to
retrieve cells
okay
so here I will print
print
a
okay okay
what I have to do is like we have
created this one file so it's it is not
giving the uh this is giving sheet1 dot
A1 why because it is taking from the
simply coders one so what I can do is I
can import this file because we have
saved data in this file
so that base is here and make it active
detective yeah so yeah you know I
haven't write here value
so that is why it is giving the cell
name and that A1 name cell name A1 only
so now it will print
aims why why names
because at the A1
at the A1 position we have names so if
you want to like print Anjali so what
you have to do is okay let me check this
B3 okay
if you want to print Anjali you have to
just write here just copy paste this
code
okay just right here the location
B3
you can see Angel is printed
so this is how you can retrieve cells
and we can do the same for the others as
to
so there is one thing like retrieving
we can change the sales values too
so just we have to write here so let me
give first enter enter for the better
visual
yeah
so here what we can write is WS
like I want to change the name of uh
name of name of
uh
I will take this A4 Smith
let me close this
okay
I will give here A4
dot value
equals to here you can give the value so
here you can write Smith you can write
John
here as a replaced value
so I will write here in as a command
change
cell
value
okay
so what you have to do is just save it
WB dot save
you have to give the path for the same
yeah
fine
so let me save this and
let me save this first and run this
first okay no error and let's open our
workbooks to see the changes
so here you can see
the changes has been implemented in our
workout
first there it was like Smith and now
John so like this you can change the
cell values and let's move forward and
see how we can merge the cells in a
worksheet
so like just close this and yeah
so
we are doing for the merging cells so
here I will write from
open py Excel
dot styles
both
alignment
so here I will write
Mars cells
for your better understanding
okay
so here I have to write WB equals to
workbook
okay let me active this workbook
WB DOT active
merge
the cell
set which one uh let's take for a while
A1
and B2
okay A and B should be in capital
letters
so after that we have to save this we
will save in this only
so I can copy I can paste it here
okay
fine
like using merge underscore cells and
after giving cell position you can
easily merge the cell so let's see the
output so let me open this simply learn
file
you can see
Nima they are merged together and like
but what if you want the values at the
same times
so you can write here I have to cut this
so you can write here like
from open py Excel
dot styles
what
alignments
alignment a should be capital
alignment
okay
so the same thing you have to write wdb
equals to
workbook
WS equals to
WB DOT active
don't have to give parenthesis
WS dot merge
underscore cells
cells
A1
B2
so here I have to give the cell value
equals to WS dot cell
which row which column so I can write
row equals to 1
column
equals to 1.
so cell
dot value
equals to
here you can give the value which you
want to print at the cell so here I will
write code with simply learn
okay fine
so what we can do this we can give the
alignment
alignment equals to
horizontal horizontal
equals to Center
and from vertical
and from vertical the same
Center
yeah let me save this file WB dot save
at the same location so I can copy the
path from here
copy here and paste here so I will
yeah seems good let me save this
white is giving error cell object has no
attribute alignment okay alignment
spelling is wrong
sorry my bad
g and m e and t
eight seems good now
oh good to go
so
so here you can see
like by giving rho equals to one column
equals to one basically position and
after giving the value to what to print
on that cell and one more thing is
alignment like it is not necessary to
give alignments like I just wrote it to
cover it uh like in video so you can
give alignments like uh right left this
time I gave the center to print in the
center
so let's
move and see the results
so you can see the value has been
printed exactly at the center of the
cell
I will make it like this you can see
the value is printed exactly at the
center of the cell because I gave the
alignment center so let's do one more
for like
to see what is the default place if you
don't give the alignments okay if you
don't give the center alignments what is
the default value so let me first remove
this okay save no issues
okay yeah
so
red align
alignments
or here what we can do is like
from
UI Excel dot styles
import
alignment
is not necessary to light import
alignments
okay this is without
okay I can write this default
leave
seems good
okay everything we have to cover from
here so I can just copy from here and
paste it here
so what we will do here we will change
the cell value we will use like C
six and B
it
sorry guys so
uh here I have to give row
equals to 6
and column must be
eight so let's make it be cs6b6
okay let's column should be six
so code will simply learn coder soft
simply learn
orders of Simply learn like we are
giving the value
so at the same time we have to just save
it WB dot save so till now we know how
to merge cell so
I repeat I hope you guys understand till
here if you have any questions or any
query regarding any code or question
just put as in comments our team will
shortly provide you the correct solution
so
moving forward
until now we know how to merge cells so
let's learn how to earn muscle okay so
let me open the code
yeah
let me open the code and write for you
so let me quickly write the code how we
can myself so we can write open
okay from
open
y
Excel
dot styles
you just I can copy this from here
I have to write here import alignments
okay alignment only
so what we are doing here we will not
give any value or any this